two
welcome everybody we are back
after what seemed like an impossibly
long break
three days baby
unheard of
i mean four technically maybe because
there's tuesdays we usually take off
yeah it's so weird when we take a day
off because
i guess it's kind of a new thing right
where we take national holidays off i
like doing it when we can me too you
guys have a good uh labor day you
celebrate yourselves
the laborers yes
uh the power that we hold is unmatched
we can work harder where would we be
without the laborers right where would
we be
show up at work um
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh you know them you'll love
them
let's
just
put it out there
i love hello fresh the super troopers
love hello fish the kids are back in
school thank god
theodore went back to school today
that did those summer breaks are two
effing long man now that i'm a parent
it's insane and and
not not because i'm like oh i want
someone to take care of my kid he has
too much energy he has no outlet it's
nuts
he's three years old
he has no outlet i mean i can't i can't
i can't tame that wild beast on my own
the kids are back in school and you can
get back on budget
hellofresh is 25 less expensive than
getting takeout it's even cheaper than
grocery shopping oh and what what else
it's better and it's healthier come on
and it's more fun
get 16 free meals
across seven boxes with code h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16
yum
yum i'm gonna say right at the top
i hate this i got a throat infection man
it's not covered it's not super covered
mega
it's not omega vega
beta zetta covered this is sick
but ila had it a couple days ago and i
was like man i'm fine
and now my throat is
messed up god right when i come back i
was so excited about today
so i'm gonna be taking it easy on my
throat man i got my robitussin
natural
which apparently is just honey
ivy leaf and it's just honey what
it's like ivy leaf whatever the [ __ ]
that is and zinc and you just it's
supposed to coat your throat it doesn't
you're not just drinking maple syrup
in a medicine bottle
no it's honey it's literally just honey
it tastes like honey
okay
and um
it's supposed to coat your throat but
yeah i just feel like i'm consuming it
tastes like beef jerky beef jerky it
tastes like beef jerky
yeah [ __ ] so how was you guys this
weekend
it was good
yeah i went to san diego it was fun
a little rocky at the end but uh it was
really nice i love san diego oh yeah you
guys got accosted by some freak janitor
we have a video of it yeah some insane
janitor made lena cry
did you guys ever report him uh not yet
what what are you waiting for get that
guy for it today for the show
well you want to show the video before
you call and report it yeah you want to
forget the feeling of the audience
sort of yeah
um
i think everyone's going to hate i think
people are going to want more than that
i think people are going to want his
head
i was mad for straight three hours after
seeing that video i had the lingering
like anger in my chest i don't know i'm
not like that
yeah i appreciate it i love texting me
outside instead
uh he commends me but he feels bad
we blurt his face so people don't go and
try to kill him knock it over my wife
exactly bro that was so you back the
[ __ ] off
well we can watch that but anyone else
have any uh
interesting uh no
no no i didn't do anything which was
awesome well
i united the empire and
total war warhammer three the immortal
empire you united the empire that's
awesome
have been united
once again under my banner
emperor carl franz
um
the orcs and the vampires they they all
tremble when they hear my name the
vampire zone they get their own
vampires
and they travel at uh during the day
uh not like an upgrade the game is sort
of abstracted beyond a day night cycle
so it's hard to say i see
[Music]
okay interesting marvel a b soundbite if
i could say so zach
i left sec so he's right
okay great well dan had an eventful
weekend i'm glad to hear that he was
very familiar wait how how was an ab
sound by this was on topic
he was saying killing orcs and [ __ ] yeah
okay okay okay no you're right you're
right you're right orcs
right well he was fighting a balrog in
that scene just to be just to be totally
clear with you zach there was a balrog
type creature although it was not part
of the orc faction it was part of the
demon's chaos so that's what i'm saying
he was fighting a battle rock okay it's
still middle or
whatever [ __ ]
uh
in other nerd news i saw john williams
conduct live this week oh yeah he was
[ __ ] awesome
he's john williams he did come on he did
the soundtrack to star wars to jurassic
park to indiana indiana jones yeah i
went going crazy i was this was me i was
soy facing the whole time
did they have to do a weekend at
bernie's thing with him because he's so
like dude he is he is young and spry for
90 years old dude he's he was nice
he did two encores and he said if you
guys keep being this nice to me i'm
gonna have to live it to be a hundred
yeah and i hope so
90 years old that man's on his on his
encore of life he was supposed to die in
80 and he just kept going you never
could tell though just how sharp and
like uh how he's waving his arms around
arthritis free that's the dream man
god will god bless
may we all live to a thousand years old
the technology is coming if not i want
my brain in the in the cloud
okay okay all right
so anyway um
we have such a fun show here today
last week we celebrated our victory over
kavkav ryan kavanagh
um
and we're commemorating ryan lavana
if you guys google ryan kavanagh
and scroll down drive angry
and click this website right run kevin
look like harvey weinstein you'll see
that he has eight days
three hours
38 minutes and 50 seconds
left to pay me
uh what he owes me in legal fees so the
time is we have not received any money
yet hmm surprise checks in the mail yeah
me too yeah i'm sure
but what we did do to commemorate our
victory
is we asked everybody to
enter in a ryan kavanaugh diss track and
we had a lot of submissions i want to
thank everybody
luke who participated do the people who
know do they know they were selected yet
or they go oh okay that's fun
no uh how many submissions do we get
what would you say olivia i listened to
probably at least 200. oh my goodness
that's that's
the people who watch this show are so
talented yeah it's crazy it's insane she
went through
the first round and kind of pared it
down to what would you say like 40 or 50
yeah that were like scarred and then we
did another pass i sat with her and we
listened to all those and
i think we wound up with like 20 and
then we were trying to get it down to
12. we couldn't do it there's 16 for the
final bracket yeah y'all are too good
yeah there's too many well to the people
that were not selected for the final
bracket tournament i apologize but i
want to thank you sincerely
for submitting we love that and we
appreciate you for those that were
selected you're gonna find out a little
bit later we've got the bracket we're
gonna have a bracket style tournament we
have cash prizes for first second and
third place
um
who's john williams jb
[Applause]
ethan the legend um
that cam went to go oh yeah see i don't
know anything about these guys yeah we
turned him down by the way
i know john williams is twice in like a
span of five minutes i didn't know him
the first time how do you think we have
to know the first time but then we just
talked about it you were giving me [ __ ]
for playing a lord of a ring sound bite
what's that got to do with me not
knowing john williams name it's like how
do you not know that it's unrelated bro
but
was related somehow dude he was fighting
a balrog that that sound bite what is
the out of the bell
well it is tolkien-esque okay so but
what i was talking about wasn't tolkien
i think is the the point you said orcs
and i'm like oh okay
fireworks yeah
no no it is fantasy actually anytime
thanks for that i just you know you laid
me up but i
i'm sick i guess maybe all right let's
blame it on that yeah but i was that was
a good one thanks bro no problem dude
john williams rocks like you know he's
got the most i know the music yeah of
course you do john williams just like
the name of every person every white
dude in america yeah
it's a very generic name i'll give you
that he has the most oscars won by
anybody though for all his soundtrack
work
like out of any oscar academy award
winner he's got him he's got the most
the goat eat a goat good for him i don't
think he'll be winning the disc track
competition today though so
we got we got danny elfman for that
anyways we had to turn down his old ass
because that's how good our audience is
damn
let's go
[ __ ] you bro
you tried to submit some like big
orchestra thing i was like [ __ ] we need
diss tracks not some epic ass yeah
yeah so let's just talk about abs
uh run in
with a deranged janitor since we're on
the topic
where we set this up for me you guys
were in san diego this is at the hotel
this is at the hotel we're leaving nice
hotel yeah in the marriott okay we're
gonna spend uh the day at uh where does
that play zach you tell me about uh
coronado coronado yes and we were
leaving the hotel and uh this gentleman
did not like that i had a skateboard
and i was in a weird situation because i
wanted to
mess this old man up all right well
let's watch
this is the right color people
last question why were you guys
recording because i found that
interesting you captured this oh i
always record i always record i never
post it anywhere but
you're always recording when we go on
vacations yeah i'm always just
practicing vlogging and i got a new mic
that i was practicing with all week um
you're just walking around that's okay
you got it man because sometimes you see
a video like this you're like why were
they even recording like oh no how did
you even capture this but here it
to be riding is here oh sorry about that
look at the signs around here
i haven't seen signs
and are you encouraging him
no no i'm not i'm just
i'm just
we're leaving right now sir have a good
day
yeah so
my favorite thing about that is he looks
at was it lena or her sister her sister
yeah he goes are you encouraging him
like are you my [ __ ] parent
he got closer to her too like he stepped
towards her when he said that yeah he
was following us like right behind us at
first you see i'm laughing because i
like i'm like does he see the camera and
thinking like just wants to be part of
the video i didn't know what's going on
i go oh [ __ ] this is serious this is for
real i didn't yeah it was a weird
situation it took some time for me to
process the [ __ ] off yeah i mean
obviously he's doing too much he's he's
a janitor i don't even think he's
security right like yeah i don't know it
doesn't even make sense what you know
he's threatened to get security no he's
not security that's what i'm saying bro
he's getting in your face and [ __ ] i
want to watch this part again because i
watch this part back a lot of times just
like man this guy
are you encouraging he's wild no no i'm
not i'm just
i'm just hoping
yeah i was like man a skateboard must
have killed this guy's family yeah like
he said no skateboarding and i picked it
up right away i didn't argue with him
anything you weren't like
like but boning out through the yeah
that's why
i put the uh lead up to this because we
literally just got down the stairs and i
put the skateboard down like it wasn't
like i was using it at all
yeah
i think tony hawk must have [ __ ] that
guy's wife or something
something
horrible security down here you got it
real funny huh
we're leaving right now sir have a good
day
were you thinking about dropping them
then
it was it did cross my mind but
i just knew that i had the girls with me
and this was their last day in
california before they go back to
michigan i didn't want to ruin their day
also i didn't feel like getting arrested
i don't know there's a lot to think of i
really did want to drop his ass
yeah you just trained man you probably
could have thrown a good one but you
were very polite i have to say i don't
think i could have been that polite in
that situation
because i'm an [ __ ] i don't know if i
could do it i probably wouldn't have
made it
any better people are saying that this
is a paid actor though ab
they would
they would yeah where's the burning car
dude
you'll see let's see lena at the end
you'll you guys could tell me if it was
acting because it was james was 100 real
i can tell you that
yeah but if he paid if he hired someone
lena and you were out of the league yeah
you might not be in on the on the scam
on the grift
it's possible i'm just saying it's
possible at least entirely paul keep
your mind open lina
i love that
there's like people walking up there too
we're in the basement of the structure
too oh okay
and then i noticed he was following the
girls so i told one of the girls to take
a suitcase in case i didn't knock his
old ass out
we're going sir we're going
like can you sound like that too zach
baby we're going sir yeah yeah
we're going sir we're going he
definitely has a serial killer face too
very tall okay yeah he's very tall i was
in sandals
i think that helped him too
sorry for the shaky camera work i'm
holding my boosted board shaking we're
walking being escorted to our car
where's the all right
okay
look he's still following us he started
between the cars at one point what a
weirdo yeah
the girls are all like clearly scared
i got i was thinking really i would like
my plan for a while was to put my stuff
in the car put the girls in the car
and then go say hi to the old man
mono
but uh
no country for old man yeah over here
look i felt bad lena was shaking
i'm shaking why are you shaking i would
have [ __ ] broke his head why are you
worried he's walking so close to us and
just eyeing us down
you're fine babe nothing would have
happened
poorly what were you thinking lina you
you were very spooked by that guy yeah i
was super uncomfortable the whole time
like he was walking right beside us me
and my sister and her friend just giving
us a death stare and more than that he
had his hand like halfway in his pocket
like he was holding something and it was
just i didn't know what to expect i'm
like what is he gonna do when we finally
get to the car it was such an awkward
walk all the way to the car and then
when we finally got there like it turned
out to be like a pocketbook that he
pulled out and he just took our plate
number
but it could have been so much worse
like i'm like is he gonna shoot us when
we get there like what's yeah
so so
i think just call the hotel and be like
yo i sent him the video oh yeah just be
like dude this guy is kind of
this guy's kind of wild he's just a
janitor bro you're supposed to like
clean [ __ ] up
not like
follow people to their urban report
some we don't need to know paul blart
down there man we just need you to like
clean up take out the trash and chip
yeah i wanted my dad's advice on how to
handle it after i sent him the video and
he goes you should have dropped his old
[ __ ] ass i was like oh for real and
he's like no not for real you you
handled it correctly
yeah you did of course you definitely
you would have been in a san diego jail
cell would have been like
you would have bet you wouldn't have
been charged because he was he was being
aggressive but maybe unless you killed
him or something i think it was possible
i think i would have
that's the thing i feel like i don't
have no middle ground well if you hit
him and he falls down and slams his head
on the concrete i'd be more worried
about the girls with me i feel like they
would have
started gang jumping
i don't know i don't think it's it's
weird i'm glad i walked away but also i
don't know what it is maybe it's toxic
masculinity but after the fact you
always feel like
i should have done something some part
of me really wishes i would have
defended our honor but yeah i know it's
better no no i mean
he's he looks like a fool
you know and you defuse the situation
everybody was fine
and i mean yeah if you end up emailing
the office he's he's going to pay for it
a lot worse than getting punched toxic
masculinity abe how dare you say that
about yourself
how did where would we be without a b
big [ __ ] weird janitors harassing
women
for skateboarding for two seconds where
would we be
when we were leaving i asked the parking
attendant what's the guy's name
downstairs and it was weird the way she
answered like she already knew she goes
okay
crazy old larry
killed someone just last week
maybe he was intimidated by the
skateboard he'd never seen one before in
san diego california right you imagine
what he would do to casey neistat jesus
yeah
yeah it turns out that um
rob dychetris actually is his he he
[ __ ] his mom and he robbed your dick
dead deer dyke whatever the [ __ ]
dear dyke
actually [ __ ] his mom john williams
[ __ ] his mom that was rough yeah
gangbang he must hate he's got some kind
of trauma with skateboards yeah that was
just unwarranted mm-hmm
turns out he was um
all right my mind's going to darker
places
let's
yeah yeah
other than that though san diego is
beautiful
great time i can't tell if these are
real uh comments or not ashley said
ethan day one fan here okay i just spent
40
trying just to let you know to stay away
from that symbol the swirly
just at least acknowledge you saw it
please
wait
the swirly yeah the swirly how do you
know that that's what they're talking
about because they donated it before oh
okay hold on let me find it well we
don't do this swirly it's the talk to
the chatters
i don't know what you're talking about
where's the first one you guys gotta
help me because it's going too fast uh
ashley about the swirlies i want to read
those donors
here let me i'm just going to go into
the my spreadsheet that has them in a
second
what are we worried about ashley
message one of the mods i want to hear
your i want to hear if you're serious or
not
[Music]
messages that are one of the one of the
one of the guys
no not the swirlies
yeah here's her first message she said
ethan please stop with the swirls
all of my ancestors all of my family we
had to have the swirl carved into our
chest for 18 months
it's a ritual that has been
inverted stop showing it
on the show please
[Laughter]
[Music]
well i'm sorry that happened to you but
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about
uh i mean that's horrible but this is
just an emoji
and it's also not something we have
control over i didn't add that emoji
look at look at what the chat is just
nothing but swirls now it i think it was
absolutely to be fair and with peace and
love i'm sorry that happened to you but
you kind of brought this on yourself
not the carving into the chest but the
no the chat the trolling with the jet
yeah
wait but tell me i'm curious about your
story i don't want to hear she said
again i wanted to say that it's a cult i
come from a long history of swirls being
engraved on our chest well
ashley
okay
we'll do we'll
we'll do our best out here ashley for
you we're gonna avoid swirling
how do you live how do you i'm just
curious how do you exist do you uh what
i mean swirls are out there right
i'm overly emotional because my grandpa
passed away today but i can't believe
how horrible that guy was
oh that one's from caitlyn
yeah ashley if you're in discord message
one of the guys i want to find out
what do we do about it
after what happened with lena please
wait what the [ __ ] does that mean
that's what the swirl girl said nothing
i don't know
maybe that lena was gonna get kidnapped
from the janitor
i think so all right swirl girl
appreciate you
just watch out for those squirrels we'll
do our best i don't control chat
and i don't even actually control the
emojis those are like
how do you say asl it's like the
standard emojis there's like a whole
committee there is a committee yeah yeah
so talk to them
what's this what's the swirl committee
called
emoji committee
the unicode emoji subcommittee
um it's an offshoot of nato
uh mark davis
appears to lead it so
maybe reach out to mark davis and
explain yeah take it up with the with
the swirl with the emoji world
government
is getting crazy i i just work here
ashley said i'm sorry i love you guys
just continue lots of therapy yeah all
right i love you man ashley you're good
you're good we love you
sorry about this world thing okay
love that
all right so
oh also we have pnp calling at two our
the world's favorite attorney criminal
attorney yes yes we're going to
ask him the uh thank you so much and
yeah very pertinent question
is what steve will do with jerking off
his dog illegal
and i don't know if he's a specialty in
bestiality laws but jerk off donny he'll
have more insight than us
p and p be like well
technically if you're going to jerk off
your dog
you don't want to talk he's like i'm pro
the crime i'm anti the time don't talk
about it do it
hit and run you know
love this is a huge dub for you pokeman
friend of the show pokemane pokemon
pokey friend of the show
how what a wonderful time we had with
her on the show she's just a great great
great gal we love her
she accepted uh the frame with love in
it and it is now sitting in her
background and yeah oh yeah
loves love's portrait is right there if
you watched the h3 podcast thank you so
much i had a splendid time
stand pokey for clear skin everybody
that's so true
she's so nice yeah she's awesome
we made a deal too underneath that video
you can see quizzing you next time yeah
i saw that yeah
you're gonna have to study bro
i was so nervous for that i wasn't sure
how i put you on the spot i put you on
the spot i know well not even the quiz
just the whole thing i was telling you i
was like bothering ian told me what to
say and [ __ ] like that he's like no i
can't help you this is all you
um and i went there i turned out pretty
good yeah turned out great are you
kidding it's a great moment yeah it's
been powerful beautiful even so thank
you guys for making that possible
elegant
this post was pretty interesting on the
subreddit somebody
i guess they described us to an ai
art
thing
and some of these are incredibly
accurate this is mine this is the worst
one in my opinion
do we know which ai generated these
i don't think they said in the uh i
think it's mid journey is the one that
did this one we gotta mess around with
that one i think it's pretty impressive
but yeah this one doesn't look like me
at all
but this one is ian i'm assuming right
no that's yeah
oh chad dan yeah it says the name on the
top right yeah at the top oh i see yeah
that one looks more like ian i gotta say
well everybody always says ian and i
look the same so
no works
that of course is um
a b
going super saiyan the bad boy
yeah
okay that's ian i see wow john krasinski
that's quite good somebody commented
saying that looks like linus tech tips
and that's all i see oh yeah this is
scruffy linus definitely
zach's this is my favorite
that's so good
i got like that russell brand hair dude
dude it's right on
it looks like hagrid on vacation this
one looks like a character from
gta vice city he's like a drug dealer on
the beach in miami
you know this one i see where it was
close it doesn't look like her
necessarily but like
interesting approach very close yeah
like there's a resemblance for sure
insane cam what the [ __ ] happened to
cameron you turned into like a gorilla
man a wookiee yeah this is me at the
fish show when i go to fish pretty good
though
uh i don't think so
i don't see it
i got i got some of that chest hair but
not quite yeah
i think it's spot-on
okay sam's is like creepily accurate
yeah sam's is the closest i don't know
how the look sam what do you think this
is insane is she here she's downstairs
oh yeah
it does look a lot like her though what
that's crazy pretty trippy it looks just
like her like the same eyebrows and
stuff too
this was definitely the closest yeah so
scary accurate
unbelievable
this is olivia i see it actually that's
pretty good yeah it's very dramatic
what am i doing just the makeup and
everything it's pretty
i don't know how they do that yeah
yeah i mean it's pretty good though
alina love that
that's very i wonder what they typed to
get us you know i'd like to see that
linus is a little cursed i'm not going
to lie like what's that
like the bot like what's going on with
your arm it's a little unnatural
what is happening with your arms
that's true that's that's a nice word
that's how the janitor saw you it's just
a monster
just impressive overall though i thought
it was pretty cool
oh here's one of love that was posted
this morning oh my god love
damn talk to me
oh [ __ ] what's up how are you doing um
i got the same same pubes facial hair
you know pubic facial hair type
super like uh
wig
[Music]
cool
i have me journey it's pretty fun i have
no clue how they made that though i've
been trying to make uh makeovers too but
it's not working how do they do it
that's so specific like so i don't know
anyway
very cool
um
phillyd [ __ ] me on twitter
oh boy
i knew this would happen
look at this 6 000 points on this
i didn't even know
are you have the the link to the tweet
because i'm missing the first part
oh yeah one second
oh my throw
something
yeah
oh i remember he posted a picture of him
skinny hiking and here it is
and i wrote something nice being
supportive of my
my good good friend phil defranco this
is my weekly midlife crisis fitness
progress post
to get validation from strangers
i said i will always validate you king
and then he decided to [ __ ] me
he said come on a hike with me you [ __ ]
face i was like oh [ __ ]
now you got me in trouble because i'm
definitely not gonna do it i could have
been like yeah sure i'll call you
i just keep i gotta keep it 100 you know
yeah keep it 55th straight i know i was
i wanted to say that but then i was like
yeah you might know
then i didn't want to
start a gang war or something
uh the chat
is
dominated by people telling you you
gotta go hiking i know that's
he's he then he goes hiker and sub is
becoming a champ he said never
i said i am now philip ethan clyde makes
me a sad boy to franco the issue
subreddit will never forgive you for
this and like you know he knows what
he's doing yeah it's just outrageous
that he would think to do this to me
after all we've been through
he said they're already turning on me
i love phillyd on twitter
what about on youtube
love on youtube as well i think he
shines the brightest on twitter actually
you know what i love his tick tocks
philly d tick tock's awesome really yeah
huh he's he's popping off on tick tock
he does little news bites what a talent
he is man he's got staying power
okay so you guys won't really want me to
go with on a hike with phil okay yeah
all right
i'll go with you guys if you want i go
hiking all the time
way to invite yourself yeah it's more
about the boy i mean it's we have to
have a mono imano i need to talk to him
one-on-one about never doing this again
to me
okay fair enough i don't want to see
that i'll go with you dan
sure now you could come with us i'm just
kidding oh can i come too uh not uab
okay
yes six thousand points what are you
afraid of ethan
keemstar's in the bushes with the blow
dart
we won't forgive
can we spam tomorrow telling ethan to go
on a hype with willip
all right maybe i'll go on the hike he
got me he did this just [ __ ] you
know he knew exactly what he's doing and
now you guys are never going to let it
go until i go on a [ __ ] hike with
philip defranco you know that with how
hot it is
you really you want to be out there at
like 5 30. it's a hundred degrees right
now okay it's like on friday
that's true it's supposed to cool off
this weekend supposed to rain this
weekend though can you hear that i did i
did that's pretty exciting there's
supposed to be
my brother's really into meteorology and
he was telling me there's supposed to be
like a monsoon potentially
well there is a hurricane or tropical
storm i mean yeah there's a hurricane
down by baja california right now and
it's heading north but it's supposed to
veer away from the coast before it
actually hits california but that will
likely bring a decent amount of rain
yeah i mean on saturday desperately need
it's not looking that that good on
saturday i was hoping for more rain than
that but um okay philly after it cools
off
after this weekend i'll go on a [ __ ]
hike with you bro just stop don't bring
the subreddit into this
it's not fair
that you bring them into this
okay
93 yes
on the poll
yes
yes oh jordan okay jordan [ __ ] yes
um
this is pretty powerful i think you guys
are going to love this the first one
somebody took the time to
um recreate vin diesel's uncomfortable
interview
that we often sample
with a playlist on shopify that says
every word he does it's very impressive
and
he
is so beautiful
thank god she's so beautiful
am i right or wrong look at her
how am i supposed to do this interview
look at this woman tell me your style
she's so beautiful corny oh man talk to
me baby
tell me your story tell me let's get out
of here let's go let's let's go have
lunch
my god i love her look how beautiful she
is thank you god wow
i found out that you are a nerd like me
you love the jews and dragons i'm
anything like you because i love you
i'm anything like it because i love you
guys really look how beautiful she is
you guys think this is a joke
first of all jesus i'm always taken
aback by what a disgust what a freak he
is in that interview
call it hr quick man
[Music]
um pretty impressive though yeah i love
when people do that
yo soy groot
you're so good
god damn my [ __ ] so good
why would they cat i was curious about
that vin diesel did the
voice of groot
right sure did
and
the
guardians of the galaxy
now this [ __ ] literally just
says groot why would you pay an a-list
celebrity just to say group get some
[ __ ] idiot
off fiverr
save a lot of money
am i wrong i mean you're right but the
other side of it is that they're getting
this a-list no and he only has to say
this dude
okay that's why
is that what they're saying he got paid
for that
for all of his appearances not just one
all of his appearance he says i'm groot
yep 55 million for that [ __ ]
it's so they could put his name his name
his name gets uh people to come to the
theaters even i didn't know he did
groot's thing i was like what it was
advertised that he was in it quite a bit
you know what man i think we need to
drag up the guillotine because this is
just [ __ ] insane 55 million dollars
for saying i am groot come on man
society's collapsing stop it they did
something similar with uh what's his
name rocket raccoon he's like bradley
cooper but most people don't even know
that i didn't know that but at least
that [ __ ] has lines true
i actually learned that afterwards i was
like what
bradley cooper he just sounds like some
dumb
cartoon raccoon he changes his voice for
it which is weird
i don't get this
just hire professional voice actors why
do we need to [ __ ]
why do i need vin diesel saying groot i
just don't get it guys
somebody explain it to me i just don't
you know and they pitch up his voice
when it's baby groot too so you don't
even know what's happening all right
so i'm saying just sending a look like
he doesn't have to show up
mf doom was this rapper who wore a mask
rest in peace
he used to send out
body doubles
put on the mask and do shows and he
would chill at home and they would just
you know
they would just play the music and he
would lip sync he was used to [ __ ] do
that
vin diesel could do that with the iron
groot lines yeah
miley cyrus when she did the hannah
montana tour for one
number when she was changing into miley
from hannah or my miley two hannah there
was a double that went out in a blonde
wig and performed a number love that
love that
she did a great job
all right vin diesel whatever the [ __ ]
i mean does she go in there and do
thousands of lives like
he just says it once right and then they
no there's all kinds of different
there's like
groot and but then
there's like
groot
they go okay vin diesel and this scene
is very tender emotional
yeah
hey vin diesel
vinnie my boy
you know speaking of celeb casting zach
was telling us earlier that howard stern
is being cast as the new uh doctor doom
you hear that [ __ ] ethan no he's not
stop it did you listen to
i have it okay well listen to it dr doom
doctor doom in what movie
uh i don't know the specific movie but
he's playing the character isn't that
like an action uh isn't that like an
action role he thinks he's gonna be
doctor doom and dog
they set up a hot mic moment he says bro
you got trolled i just googled it it
says how we're starting trolling
internet about dawg that was
video was from july okay
he confirmed it yesterday
on the air
who would play doctor doom in mcu
fantastic four michael fassbender
howard stern
dude think how awesome that would be
listen i typed howard stern
dr doom the only thing that comes up is
the trolling that's just some youtube
video from july okay wait here
did howard stern just leak marvel
studios dr doom plan
so there was a hot mic moment which i
feel was set up of course it was um
before he went on break because you know
he goes for two three months
um
just there the transcripts in there i
think in that article
of what was said
during a commercial break the howard
stern's cruise mics were left on by the
way this is like the biggest show in the
world they don't make mistakes like that
never
well neither do we we're we're we're
almost done yeah i mean even weird don't
make mistakes like that yeah
it's a mike stone so anyway yeah i'm
about to uh
i think that only happened with jimmy
jimmy kept his mic caught and went in
the bathroom like that audio audio in
the restaurant yeah
bro there's no way there's no way
listen to yesterday's show here it is
that's all i'm saying here's here's
great
yeah you're right what the hell man
people are insane
okay i mean listen i'm interested i
think he's a good actor i like it but i
don't think it's real they said downey
jr would be bad at iron man
they said toby i didn't say he'd be bad
everyone here is like just talking [ __ ]
on it i think it would be cool exactly
no howard's a good actor he is i'm
talking
i'm not talking [ __ ] i think he's gonna
do a cameo in the movie exactly i don't
think i think
he's not playing doctor doom yeah 68
year old he showed me all the evidence i
looked it all over this morning he was
even more insistent i think he's backed
off a little bit because he's on the
show but this morning he was like very
insistent i'm still full force listen
and dan made a good point we never know
when zack's trolling like we we don't
know if he's serious or if he's just
doing a bit about this but he's like he
has serious sustainability
i'm realizing it is serious how are
stern's 70 years old the man is six five
he this is like an action role doctor
doom he's a supervillain and also like
just pick like picture howard stern's
voice coming out of that character like
an old new york jew yeah hype is [ __ ]
dude it just makes no [ __ ] sense it'd
be hype as [ __ ] and you want it to
happen bro this is what they said this
is
this i got intel that uh richard simmons
is going to be playing yeah that's right
that he came in
he came back that reminds me did you
hear who they recast for t'challa and
black panther yeah brian cranston no way
i already made that joke earlier wow
yeah guys uh i'm announcing here today
uh turn off the mics real fast it's just
just for you guys to hear yeah okay
they're off
yeah so i just got an email from the
casting director of the marvel universe
turns out i'm gonna be playing um
go to card ian go to cards
bothers me to still see myself here
while we're not live turns out i'm gonna
be playing here i just googled the worst
characters in the marvel universe i went
to card okay yeah just yes so i'm
actually playing
um
uh how is this the worst hold on i'm
just looking for a given
bill o'reilly's on this list
bill o'reilly is who he's the worst
character in the marvel universe
what
what
oh he must just show up on the news in
like once he did a cameo early movies do
it
live worst
worst marvel hero you like hawkeye i
think but yeah i mean we already here's
a good one
all right let's do this again
yeah so turn off the mics real fast
they've been off yes so i just got an
email from the casting director for
marvel no way i'm playing leather boy
leather boy
is that the guy in like the [ __ ] suit oh
yeah he has that cannon yeah yeah he is
cannon bro leather boy
oh that's a great role for you the mere
sight of leather boy's shiny black
costume is enough to have readers
clawing their eyes out that's the role
of a lifetime dude yeah y'all are so
funny until this [ __ ] happens
i think it's gonna happen but he's gonna
send out a body double like mf2 that's
fine he can voice him
it's his voice oh wait no no no
olivia there's actually they were asking
if you're interested in playing asbestos
lady
oh yeah i said yes
you accepted that role yeah yeah oh a
brilliant chemist gone crazy victoria
murdoch became asbestos lady after
creating fireproof clothing using
asbestos
no [ __ ] way character i love her
hey hold on guys i think they're very
well i think the mics might be on oh no
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh no [ __ ] oh no it's a live show what
are we gonna do about it oh god i hope
no one clips this i just got an email
they fired me oh for waking up
hey zach
they were they were wondering maybe they
thought you'd be good for this character
dr bong
ultimate stoner oh yeah these are all
real heroes by the way
literally yeah litter bug or paste pot
pete anybody
hmm
he's just like a hindsight lad the weird
kid that eats paste grown up
and pot stickers
let's see hindsight lads
easily one of the most annoying
superhero characters ever
hindsight lad has the amazing ability to
say knowing things like if only we had
done it my way amidst destruction
oh that's awesome
yeah so uh don't guys don't tell anyone
it's supposed to be top secret all i'm
saying is go back and listen to the
episode that's all i'm saying fassbender
i read is going to play doctor doom now
this i get
voiced by word stern spreading that
misinfo
i hope howard stern gets it
i'm there i'll watch you i don't give a
[ __ ] i mean i'm a fan
i want zach to be right but there's no
shot you're right zach i'm sorry listen
to the episode ethan will you you
promise me you'll listen yeah okay okay
okay that's all i want what you're
saying
yeah actually heard um
harvey weinstein's coming back to play
kingpin
wow no way
and they recast they got rid of tom
holland you know he's done
so they're bringing in anthony hopkins
that's that's interesting that is
interesting a young teenage
peter parker here wait i'm confused i
thought harvey was going to play uh
homelander
hmm
well that's not part of the marvel
universe right
you can juggle it you know
everyone likes tom holland
they recast though they found someone i
think is going to work better paul
rubinfeld
pee-wee herman paul rubio yeah his name
is i was like who's that what the [ __ ]
google said paul reubenfeld no that's
rob robert dyke's cousin look at this
[ __ ] i said oh
herman actor named paul
ruben's uh might be a stage name then
and that's his real name
my bike way to go you just doxed him wow
you doxed him in that theater this guy
got dirt done dirty man his whole career
got sidetracked before he's jerking off
in an adult theater what else do you
think goes on in there he came back
though like he got a netflix he's fine
but he lost he was pee wee herman the
world was on
he's back to being pee-wee
he did like a netflix thing yeah he's
back
i stand pee-wee i wonder if that was
just like a homophobia thing because
that happened back in the day when
people were like gay people or demons
not gay it wasn't in a theater like that
it was in an erotic theater but it was
not gay no no
all right getting set
all right
just let it hang just let it hang all
right guys that was a good pride minute
five minutes
i thought he was gay [ __ ] all right well
then what are they doing what do you
know you're probably thinking of he had
a very prominent role in the movie blow
where he did play a gay man is that
perhaps where you got that idea from
may let's just say yes that was a great
movie great part for him let's do a
prime minute in honor of uh this guy off
okay
guys
paul reuben excluded from this minute
this one's not for you
all my lgbtq plus people in the audience
get that gay energy out okay
oh i'm not timing [ __ ] after a minute i
have something to say
get those gay get those gay vibes out of
you because how long have we been going
it's not your opportunity 30 seconds
okay we'll get another thousand gay
vibes out
kiss a man
or a woman
whatever it is just be proud of yourself
man you know nobody can tell you
who you are
who you need to be
and by the way nobody should be blamed
for something that they were born into
i mean just be you
not you paul reuben not your minute all
right time's up
back in the closet the hell out of you
all right listen i got a good conversion
therapy for you guys you losers
how about you guys we try being normal
huh and shame on you
you know you brought it all onto
yourselves by being gay all right shame
on you all
back in the closet
i will say thank you online a lot of
people have asked that question and i
guess at one point he said that he's not
interested in the other sex but that
does not make him gay but that's where
some of the confusion may have come from
i think he might be gay dan wait are you
thinking of richard simmons i'm not
thinking of richard simmons but i'm how
could he confuse richard simmons no he's
not gay he's they're both flamboyant
gentlemen
the names are completely different
so um anyway regardless he should he
needs to be deeply ashamed at this
moment he missed pride minute
i mean and it's just
give me the uh the god music please
and jesus said
suck and ye shall not
touch another man's penis that's the
holy spirit
for our world will drown in sin and test
terrible pain
i am furious with some men
i made a man's penis look scrumptious to
test your faith boy you changed now
if it was up to me we'd all be able to
suck on a fat juicy
milk inducing [ __ ]
but i'm here to say i test you now boy
hallelujah
do not waste that sweet milk
hallelujah
now i won't
i just want to say y'all heard about the
famines
the famines going on in uh where's their
famine and like
they're yemen
it's probably many other places every
time you touch a dick an african child
starves to death boy i got my prostate
milked by ethan klein that means deleted
that needs to go away you know
i'm gonna agree with that
i'm not wanting to be involved in that
one either that's gotta go don't let our
hr hear that
[Music]
hallelujah
let me get some crosses in the chat now
put that gay real deep down
let's just forget it's even there
god said
if you sleep with if you lay down with
another man
[Music]
i will
put florida underwater hallelujah the
whole state boy
you're asking for the bible and the more
dicks you suck
speared the more inches of dick you suck
for every inch of dick you suck another
inch the ocean rises my shoulder amen
amen
and it gets muggy down there in houston
it sure does
oh god that's good oh these couplings
are just amen
but son
you ain't never seen heart did he say
hassan
he said son you've never seen hot do i
play that again
sounds like he's saying hassan ain't
never seen heart
all right thank you
[Music]
oh my throat is so messed up wow wow
stop it right now all right uh pmp will
be here in just a moment
so um so let's go so so
just to be clear
to all the freaks the conservative
[ __ ] lunatics haters
who say that they go well what's next we
let a man marry a man what's next a
man's gonna marry a dog
well i just want to be clear steve will
do it is not allowed in our
pride minute i did not come on my dog
bestiality you don't
you with me
you're excluding uh what is zoophilia is
that what it's called no zoophilia you
guys do your own thing man don't include
us
nothing to do with you
jerk off donnie if you want to jerk off
donny that's a whole different movement
okay
you work on that by yourself
in fact maybe stay in the closet
sometimes i mean sometimes being in the
closet i like when it comes to
bestiality in the closet
you know what i mean
jrh nbr
back in the closet steve
can we get conversion therapy for uh
jerking off your dog
jerk off donny
yeah
all right so pmp's gonna uh
call in and uh give us a legal analysis
you just popped into the waiting room
don't show that why would you do that
who did that
did what showed the picture of of
joji making that face at me
why'd you do that love
how dare you
making it funny
how
yeah
okay never more no i'm just kidding go
ahead pull up pnp all right i'm bringing
them in
i'm just kidding love just yeah i know
yeah okay good
but i understand it's a very
it's a sensitive moment
so um america's favorite uh attorney
let's go
he is connecting his audio standby well
actually while we're waiting he has a
new banger that showed up on my feed
here we go all right we're right there
yeah we are hold on one sec uh
hold on hold on one sec uh buddy uh what
was your name again i just call you pmp
david yeah david my man
john williams like the king
my kingdom
hashem my brother
my brother
okay wait one sec i want to watch your
new video i'm with my great client here
we're in downtown l.a
this was his second dui
uh he crashed with another car the fire
department came
ambulances came
he volunteered the breathalyzer test
that is totally optional
sometimes it's a mistake he blew a 0.25
percent blood alcohol content the legal
limit is only 0.08
they arrested him and took him to the
station
he did
another breath test there
and he blew a point two six percent
uh this was initially a felony arrest
but we're pleased to announce that he
did not get a felony he got a
misdemeanor
and he got zero jail time
all he's got to do is an alcohol class
for nine months 20 aa's
some community service
and then after three years we can
expunge his record and it'll show up as
the case got dismissed how do you feel
fantastic thank you so much
let's go
oh
there's a little stack right now
let's go yeah the top comment is get
this man
i'll get this man his keys
get him a drink
hey you know what don't you ever um
don't you ever worry that you're ruining
their life by blowing them up on
tick-tock
uh
you know what in the beginning i was a
little concerned because people were
really wild and like
people were hating like crazy ethan
and uh
i think after i was on your podcast last
time you know you guys got such good
followers the people that watch your
show
are such kind of positive people
that
i feel like they've come to the rescue
in my comments and they've had my back
so a lot of my comments are now positive
or at least like they're drowning out
all the haters
let's go
let's go let's hello guys
yeah but like if a prospective employer
saw you talking about how this dude was
like clawed out of the jaws of life
after attacking a cop
probably wouldn't you know what i mean
like if they well
his name's not in the tick tock right so
why would he see it
so here's the thing i'm not running for
congress anytime soon no not you them
i mean they can't they're wearing a mask
you know they can't be identified even
though coved like is
you know the restrictions aren't around
anymore and you're not required to wear
a mask in court uh i tell my clients you
know i talk to them hey are you going to
be willing to do a video with me if you
don't mind you know would you do it and
if they say yeah which
only like one or two people who have
ever said no uh if they say yeah i tell
them hey i'd appreciate it if you can
bring a mask so i can keep you anonymous
because i don't know people out there
knowing who you are responsible
that's how it is smart smart smart well
let's move on i brought you on today and
so nice to see you again david how have
you been by the way since our last
appearance you were such a hit i hear
that the comments section is turned
positive for you which i love to hear
have you got any calls from from super
troopers uh fans of ours who got who hit
and run drunk or
uh or he beat some children or whatever
it is
kids beat kids up that was one of your
clients
wait first of all i missed you and uh
you know it's life's been great i hope
life's been good for you too yeah yeah
thank you
uh who's koopa troopers oh that's just
the name that's just one of the names we
call our uh fans it's a little
embarrassing i'm sorry i've seen that
around and i was curious what is that
well it's like you know what a fupa is
you know what a fupa is
is that like the section like in between
your stomach and your life yeah
so i'm fat and then so and then you know
what a koopa troopa is for mario yeah of
course yeah so fupa troopa
it's kind of stupid love that
yeah sorry about that
but anyway
have you got any uh have you any clients
uh reach out from the show
i have you know what uh the day we did
the the last show
my phone was blowing up mostly with
people who
just wanted legal advice and i spent
like a few hours just giving people
legal advice
um a lot of the calls were not
areas of law that i practiced a lot of
people
you know dealing with like divorces or
child custody and stuff like that and i
try to help out whoever i can
there's a lot of people suffering out
there
and you know i just try to do my part in
just helping whoever comes to me asking
for help
uh even if it i'm not going to get any
money for it
i have retained a few clients
wow wow nice watch the show all right
let's go i don't know how many probably
like like maybe two or three
um and you know i've been doing good
work for them love that
report back i can't wait to see one of
our fans getting blasted on tick tock
you gotta let that we might have one
soon for you
my man helping out the people all right
so i i called you in today i'm glad
you're doing well david
thank you a lot of by the way lots of
thirst trapping for you did you get any
inquiries from women who were looking to
yeah of course yeah definitely yeah yeah
i did um you know i i didn't pursue
anything uh
but it was definitely
interesting to watch and my business
partner also has access to our instagram
instagram profile and
you know he was like oh why don't you
message this one back take this one out
take this one out and
you know i'm just steered clear
smart man that's a good choice there i
appreciate that yeah i don't i don't
want you like hitting and quoting any of
my fans david
yeah david if you sleep with one of my
fans you got to marry him you understand
that right
no of course yeah yeah yeah if you hurt
one of my fans i'll kill you you
understand that right you know i i
totally yeah of course i gotta go
no let's not do this to poor david um
so the reason i i asked you to call in
today
as i told you on tick tock we have an
urgent and uh immediate important matter
to get your take on
there's a there's a big youtuber so many
years his name is steve will do it
he did a podcast recently where he
confessed in great detail to how he
jerks off his dog
and i was curious if you have any
insight to the legality of this i'll
play you a brief clip okay
um
can can he see this guys
it's a clip of him talking about it or a
clip of him actually in the ass
yeah i wouldn't do that to you he's
talking about it i mean i wouldn't care
you know i've seen something yeah you're
a lawyer yeah i'm trying to get that
story i'll tell you a story after this
okay great
yeah so can you see this david
yeah okay honestly i missed my ex girl
from the dogs
i missed i swear i really missed that's
dude that's the thing oh dude when we
broke up we broke up for eight months
right how how i started talking to her i
started messaging donald on instagram i
really miss her dogs man
yeah dogs are dope selena um our dog
star is like is he's recently he's been
like you come home and they're just come
everywhere what are you talking about
come over the couches
and did you see it you see the [ __ ]
yeah usually he comes stains and his
dick is like all big and throbbing so
like it sucks is it illegal to describe
a dick's a dog's dick as
big and throbbing
not illegal
and is showing this much thigh illegal
or no
no no okay thanks not in my jurisdiction
okay all right we'll keep moving
this is like kind of crazy i'm saying
this but
one
i'm the cool dad now okay
i'm the favorite you're the favorite of
the coolest and two
you can control where the [ __ ] goes
what are you talking about
how do you do this
so i get ivs all the time yeah yeah i
know you know they wear gloves yes so
lately i've been just like groceries ago
you put on the glove and you said donald
he's going on his stomach or like on
something right here or like you go cow
style cow stuff because the cow styles
what do you talk about for catching and
then you go and usually just play like
uh like uh like i like cartoon like
disney like family friendly and [ __ ] uh
and he's
has been uh i've been just like jerking
off donnie jerking your dog off i swear
that's
yeah they go on and on
but there's the admission
now obviously there's laws against what
you can and can't do to animals right i
mean we have so so can you jerk off a
dog here uh pnp is my question for you
david dear david beautiful day right so
first of all it's illegal there are
crimes
uh
like bestialities illegal animal abuse
illegal
uh
however him just admitting it
is not chargeable
there is a legal doctrine called the
corpus delecti rule
which means you can you cannot be guilty
of a crime if the only evidence
are is your admission there has to be
your admission plus
some other evidence right so you can
call his ex-girlfriend and say hey is
this your dog have you noticed anything
weird
boom you can then there could be
something actionable so if he was
collecting his the dog semen maybe
in some kind of like uh container that
would maybe be considered evidence
there we go if they found it if a judge
issued a warrant based on probable cause
from his admission they found something
they can charge him but just him you
know
speaking on the podcast is it's not
going to be chargeable but it's
definitely a crime and i got a story for
you guys if you want to hear it it's
pretty damn nasty but it's about a case
that uh
came across i came across when i was a
prosecutor
i'd love to hear it i'm sure it's good
coming from you
it's uh it's pretty gnarly man i'll tell
you that but
so
i'll tell you the story
there is a family that has a in them all
right first of all they have a big
german shepherd in their backyard
that's the boy
and they have a gardener that comes once
a week and they started noticing that
oh our german shepherd starts acting
weird on the days our gardener comes and
we don't know what the hell is going on
so they install a surveillance camera in
the backyard
and it's kind of it's like installed
like kind of on the roof and you can see
down into the backyard
so
the surveillance tape
showed the following things so it's
if you see the gardener coming to work
he opens the door to the backyard and he
comes into the backyard and he's holding
a rake
and
like a cloth bag i guess to like rape
like leaves into
the dog immediately comes and starts
like jumping on him and you know he's
excited to see the guy
and the guy like rakes a little bit you
know and like looks around he puts the
rake in the bag away
and
i swear he starts taking his pants off
and i'm watching this thing to thinking
like oh my god is he back to the dog
like holy [ __ ]
no
it's crazier than that he does not [ __ ]
the dog
he starts crouching
and the dog starts getting up behind him
and he lets the dog [ __ ] him
let's go
no okay that's just good dog no wait so
okay at this point
go ahead you can fit it i have questions
yeah go ahead and dog [ __ ] him okay
not long like maybe like 10 seconds if
even
until the dog comes i guess the dogs
like like come fast i don't know
maybe he just got a nice butthole david
you consider that
you're gone
maybe he just has a tight butthole you
consider that
you know what somebody's finishing
that's why you gotta put down dogs
maybe
he takes a handkerchief out of his like
like little pocket in his shirt he wipes
his ass
puts it back puts his pants back up and
starts getting back to raking
and that's and we charged him
that's a lot man i'm gonna die
that's a lot i have questions so
do you think was the dog actually
penetrating him do you think
i think so i don't know
what the [ __ ]
i mean and then when i think the dog
came
the dog came he wiped the cup
gotta stop saying that
uh ela's watching she gave ten dollars
and said
no
well that's that's great man i love
talking to you because you always got
some [ __ ] to share i love that
so when he continued to rake
what was the dog doing
he's chilling smoked a cigarette he had
some post not clarity who knows
what kind of weird behavior was the dog
exhibiting that concerned them
i don't know i have no idea we didn't
get into that and then so
so
did they come to you with this video
evidence or how did this go down
how did you it was just a file
at the office in
the way it works in criminal
prostitution
uh
whereas like right now someone hires me
i'm the lawyer for you from start to
finish
in prosecution there's different kinds
there's vertical prosecution and
horizontal prosecution
vertical prosecution is you got one
prosecutor that's assigned to this case
who's gonna see this through to
conviction or whatever all the way
horizontal is just
you know my boss told me to go staff
department two or whatever so i'm in
this one courtroom all day
and i don't know anything about these
cases and i'm just going through them
working on them as they come and
tomorrow whenever you know whoever
prosecutors in this courtroom is going
to be the one dealing with these cases
so i just happened to come through you
know see what this case was about real
quick i did not i was not assigned to
this case
i just you know worked on it a little
bit and that was it yeah i would say
this is definitely a horizontal uh issue
here
nah not so much vertical in this in this
case
so you
sideways i'll tell you that
so you didn't you don't know anything i
was just curious about like the police
came and got him
you know i want all the details but it
sounds like you don't have
i don't i didn't see this one through
eila said she just put on the show as
you still was telling the joke
i'm on my door but but i mean listen if
you were defending the guy who got
railed by the dog
i feel like you could have some plus
with an ability i mean he didn't [ __ ]
the dog the dog [ __ ] it
i mean maybe he should sue them it's
like yo your dog assaulted me what's up
there's an angle there right david
you know what ethan you are such a
genius and you're right i mean look he's
just sitting there
and whatever came to him came to him you
didn't touch the dog or anything
something there now i think we can get
one out of one juror out of 12. right
you only need one right
one you know at least yeah do you know
anything about it if he was what was he
sentenced to or anything
uh from what i heard is that he was
convicted
loved that for him yeah should have
hired david there you go uh steve will
do it eat your heart out
can i ask besides all that how is his
yard work yeah
how'd the garden look be damn good man
backyard
flourishing unfortunately you fired the
guy
but
you know that's a tough choice you know
it's like
well he's such a good guard it's so hard
to find on one hand
he loved his job yeah yeah he did too
much yeah
i wonder how many dogs he was
he was letting rail him man
yeah
oh boy i wonder
what the hecking dog probably had
i must say that i've had some
post-coital regrets about that phrase
yeah yeah yeah all right listen david
you continue to be the man
we love you
and once we have another pressing uh
legal matter i'll reach out and
hopefully you got time
uh for that one feel free
any time i'm always down you're going to
trial right now
what's that you going to trial right now
uh actually my business partner is in
trial right now pretty difficult car
accident case so
i'm just uh manning the fort
all right well let's let's get that
monster back on the road all right let's
do it let's go
let's go
let's go
all right david we love you all right
talk soon buddy
yeah so from what i worked out from
david our legal consultant uh our
is that it is illegal but we would need
there's not enough to pin the crime but
it is illegal what he's doing
for sure yeah for sure
no evidence that we know of
yeah
that's so interesting wow david we love
him
the the man let the dog [ __ ] him in the
ass you've got to love it don't you
let's go got him
this is america man
do a little gardening
no bucket is required
doesn't sound like any bucket was
required for that
oh yeah
all right let's get to the main event
here i'm gonna uh uh cav cav diss track
competition
the moment we've all
been waiting for here we have a bracket
everyone watching who submitted you're
about to find out
here
are our finalists who are now going to
compete
in the ryan kavanaugh diss track
competition
uh this is huge guys i'm actually gonna
go to the bathroom before we get started
but uh once again first place 500
second place 300 third place 100 and
also just
clout the clout is
that's the real prize
really is
in fact maybe we can embed the winner
on the website
love would you oh
okay we would be easy to do just let me
know
also i encourage you guys to upload
these with ryan cavanaugh in the title
on youtube just you know
yeah
so this is easy to find it's easy to
find if you type his name these will
come up we're gonna go to the bathroom
we'll be right back and we'll get
started
[Music]
hi dan
hey was that you cam there was me hi how
you doing good how are you anyone here
from arizona i'm good i'm not from
arizona i've never been to arizona have
you
yeah i've been to arizona many times
love you you used to wrestle gators in
arizona is that right
yeah i mean that was my previous
occupation uh you know it gets kind of
hectic over time so i had to put that
behind me but yeah
well it's hard to find them out in
arizona seeing as there's right after
i'm done with it yeah yeah yeah i was
one of the last alligator guys oh i see
you're they cleaned up town
yeah yeah you
did a gator genocide
what hitler was with the alligators wow
for gators
excuse me i see love is more of a saint
patrick don't let me break this down
love is more of a st patrick figure in
my mind st patrick suppose i don't know
any of these people got the saints or
the snakes out of ireland love got them
the gators out of arizona
yes i mean at the end of the day it's
very invasive in the desert yeah for the
cactus
[Music]
this is great impromptu yeah
what what what did someone say about the
troubadour
[Music]
heard that there's somebody who's
playing right literally zach wastely
here's the door
[Music]
the mics were muted they were muted that
was weird that was weird
that was weird that was weird
did you mute me zach no the whole night
whenever ian hit the button it just
a little glitchy glitch
little glitchy glitch go ahead you were
saying
oh yeah someone said something about the
troubadour
zach lewis i don't think so like nobody
said anything about the game oh i might
heard it you know no i just actually
rewound the episode and took another one
oh well you know you mentioned that up
you just mentioned trouble so you know
zachary was live with the troop door
january 13th who's zach lewis
i
i'll be there yeah i'll be there buddy
love you cam love you a b i bought my
ticket already
dan
dan
dan thoughts
what are you asking me are you going to
be there
i'll be at the troubadour yeah okay
i don't know january what i don't know
what yeah uh january 13th
not that day no oh yeah sorry for john
fogerty
i'm going for vogue for the phone yes
but if you want tickets just google zach
lewis
good time good tunes zach lewis
troubadour
i gotta say zack i'm surprised you
haven't asked for enough here it is
photoshop a promo for it yeah that's
coming yeah i'm sure it is twenty
dollars that's a good that's a steal i'm
not giving you down time cam before
between shows
we just got done with this other show
he's gonna ask very soon
well i'll be ready always ready for zach
live at the troopadeer troubadour
january whatever the hell
well thank you cam
[Music]
ethan's making his way back he's washed
his hands i'm excited to hear their old
hand washer i must say
very thorough
not a drop of piss on those massive
hands
that are now in the salami do it
hungry hit me with that new trump
feeling [ __ ]
you guys hear that trump actually did
steal nuclear records i sure did
i sure did yeah top secret
they were so top secret
that evening like
yeah what was that i have a write-up
here it says only the president some
members of his cabinet or near cabinet
level officials could authorize other
government officials to know the details
of these special access programs
uh the such documents were stored in
mar-a-lago
for more than 18 months after he left
the white house
they were nuclear secrets of another
country you know what the most
interesting uh
wrinkle in all of this is they're also
saying they found a hundred documents
bearing classification markings along
with scores of empty folders
intended
so they're like the folder that says
classified all over the front or
whatever and the document inside is
missing which is awesome
who's defending this guy this is nuts
he definitely sold that [ __ ] off right
or do you think he's misplaced nuclear
secret i don't i don't [ __ ] know what
to think they open the file up and it's
a
mcdouble
wrap
in the manila envelope
i just think it's funny i just think
but
enough of that
we're here to celebrate ryan cavanaugh
do it
pull out let's take a look at the uh
bracket okay so
it's up first
let me finish my salami
here we're starting on the uh left side
of the bracket here so we know
cooper
knight ecker
j fella or jade
bella philla fella
bella
anonymous j
azel
jimmy dk
gooney gunnardo
dirt mouth
and joe sanders
that's that's the first half of the
bracket
all right let's get started first we're
gonna do the first bracket here cooper
yes nydeker and versus or jay fella
first j phillip and then we'll take a
vote
everyone's going to vote to decide who
was the better uh
better uh disser
so with that being said let's start
right from the top with cooper's
cooper
knight eckers uh
ryan kavkev
diss track
uh am i opening it i'm um right
i have a link to youtube i can do it too
whatever you want
hold on whatever you want boss man
yeah why don't you play it okay there's
the clip go look for the clip
all right and some of them have videos
by the way
fantastic we love that some did videos
in fact the first one did now there's a
this person was recognizable to you uh
was it was he not
um olivia
it was to me oh you recognize actually i
follow this guy on tick tock okay so
he's rocking the frenemies oh he's got
the merch he's got the birthday family
yeah this is cooper
wait there's more costume change
so here we go
[Music]
[Music]
now you're a bankrupt poor man everybody
bagra doorman money ethan bankrupt
teddy fresh makes racks you're poor
teddy fresh makes bang you're broke
ela cry knows how to run
[Music]
wow wow okay
first of all very good and also galore
zach at the truman what the [ __ ]
god did you put that in beyond
absolutely not my hand to god
is that going to do something
that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well the one thing i'll say first of all
loved it
amazing performance
great rhymes
i love how deep the lore was
the man is a fan of the show
no question about it that's cooper
nydeker incredible so that first one is
bankrupt
poor
poor man maybe i should open it so we
can see the bracket or uh sure yeah why
don't you want to
operate the
so are you in the google playlist the
playlist or the google drive folder just
the playlist if you go to the playlist
they're all in order
all right so moving on to our next
competitor to going head-on jay fella
with a wonderfully titled [ __ ] ryan
kavanagh
which i'm saying every morning
here it is
uh-oh age-restricted it was just because
the
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yo let me tell you a little story it's
sad
it's about your boy cab kevin brad the
boat my wife wants it every night
morning and afternoon i know she's my
wife but rather you can have it too
cause there's a few things i treasure in
life
[Music]
is enough of a first impression they
call them cut cuz up in his first
direction getting slandered in the media
at home in bed like dear wikipedia like
writing mean things
[Music]
why you dressed so childish trailer
these things flip freezer delinquent and
don't get me started and why your jeans
got sequence you're a [ __ ]
millionaire get your teeth fixed can't
even pay a nanny man that cabbie's a
cheap [ __ ]
[Applause]
harvey weinstein looking ass [ __ ]
[Music]
man
[Music]
all right so i'm throwing up the pole
super impressive i mean first round
knockouts man
this there's i'm telling you the talent
is unbelievable and there's also like
variety we were i was going through them
this morning so many genres yeah it's
incredible
also yeah they both sound totally
different both a great delivery
um
but
wow i'm just so impressed this is going
to be such a fun segment yep
well i got to say that someone took a a
pretty large lead here
uh the winner of this battle is pretty
much decided it's j
fellas
[ __ ] ryan kavanagh yep
and thank you cooper the submission was
incredible i loved it jay fella just
went so so hard that was just slapped so
hard man
wow that was great yeah that's a clear
winner so i'm going to wrap the pole up
there and uh we can move on to our
second bracket which is anonymous j
versus zazel
all right anonymous jay coming in
uh oh he yeah he has a quote at the
beginning here we go
just publicly slapped trailer founder
ryan cavanaugh in the face with his dick
oh my god
60
963 in attorney's fees unpaid wages for
leagues of employees
more likely to swerving trees from a
bourbon breeze wet and reckless deep in
depths of his bankruptcies if it's wine
stains and ponzi schemes this weinstein
who you've probably seen no cab i mean
battering in the courtroom recording
natalie portman before padamay
[Music]
[ __ ] is flipped
diddy said we don't [ __ ] with trella
we've been named [ __ ] with trilla the
day that he [ __ ] with illa he's simon
silda l sentence in the check for a
quarter million benefactor or cap with
plaque and tartar building
[Music]
[Music]
my free speech
business or a marriage merrily all
sincerity go to hell or share a cell in
a skill house all the males in your
wheelhouse 50 cent for the bailout this
force of nature got forced to take a
foreskin down this track with these
coconuts from jamaica smears make up
heck and vader supposedly generated this
mega following all of them holograms out
of facebook meter robotic fans like the
12 year old out the himalayas the
surfboarder from california
congratulates you the nerf herder from
outer space left a smiley face your
friends lister all mr smith from
assimilation don't ever come for our
first amendment diverse malignant no
controversy when i say verses of swiss
and timberlands your own attorney and
blind jury can see resemblance only you
not paying anything increases interest
of all people why would they go after
someone who defined copyright law of
reaction video
it's just else on top of it
back then i was broke now i'm [ __ ]
rich let's be honest
[Music]
you literally have [ __ ] you money and
you're using it
[Music]
i'm happy to send that president so yeah
[ __ ] you
[Music]
i mean at this point with the way the
trailer's hemorrhaging money i might
even be richer than ryan kevin
i definitely will be by the time trailer
goes bankrupt
it's
[Music]
giving me mf doom vibes kind of with the
flow yeah the flow is the flow is
immaculate definitely
i just this is incredible the talent the
talent people how are we gonna decide on
a winner the production value on that
was really cool there was some great
automation
panning going on that was really cool
anonymous jay
what a [ __ ] legend well let's move on
his opponent
is a a rapper known as
azazo
azazel
uh az azazel lazy
as zazel a z
there's more than what's written there
uh that's how i have it written
on the video
oh i see on the on the bracket yeah i
guess on the on the actual original file
it says az okay azel az let's do it
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
let's make a list all of this [ __ ] that
you did a coward on a power trip sour
from hours you spent on a business just
being [ __ ] to get flipped now you're
driving angry everything you touch just
die you're gangrene if i wash your kids
would you even pay me if i [ __ ] your
[ __ ] would you probably thank me
reckless best bet was to let it get dick
brad was a ball and a best friend might
be your best investment everything else
is less than let's see relativity
relatively empty no hits in a century
ponzi is putting it lightly that's just
according to variety oh that reminds me
of the time that you lied under oath
that your coldprez
[Music]
so does natalie
[Music]
know
[Music]
could have stayed rich in anonymity
filling up words to infinity like so
many other bozos in the industry why
they all looking like gold cheese
know what i mean i can't tell if it's
ryan or weinstein i might have to google
it see what i find there may be a city
for people like me visit a few times and
find it enlightening copyright strike
and we strike like lightning there's a
fight night and i'm michael tyson wanna
be a dana white you not like him people
like him and they hate you
couldn't get a pay-per-view even if you
paid for views on the high seas no one
pirates you h3 part only time that
you're ryan hill in the spotlight and
that's kind of proof you're not that guy
you're a lion guru hey
didn't have to lie when i wrote this got
a little high and a flow [ __ ] climbed
[Music]
how can you even decide between those
two or so both of those were fire it's
gonna be tough i honestly don't know who
i honestly don't know who to vote for um
yeah well we're gonna have to make a
choice
jay
versus zazzle zee
wow
both coming hard both super talented
golly i don't know who to vote for
all right the poll has been posted let's
see what the audience thinks i honestly
[Music]
wow okay a lot of people saying they
can't choose
[Music]
get your votes in guys we're starting to
roll in
man that was just they were both so
impressive you know i heard the first
one i said there's no way the second
one's gonna be as good
and now the second one's got me all
confused with yeah
and actually
looking at the vote now it looks like
azal's
assault
zozo a-z azazel az is taking a fairly
significant lead right now 60 to 40
it it is but it
it is tightening
as the votes continue to roll in every
every update it's getting closer so
let's maybe just i don't know if he can
close that gap i mean it's pretty wide
but let's see 59.41 it's still closing
uh see if it anonymous j fans get your
votes in still closing a little bit as
long as it's trending in that direction
i think let's just see where this goes
yeah do it anonymous j fans get your
votes in now
well
uh it's updated and it stayed at 58.42 i
think that might be it
well it just almost ticked over 57.43
it's still like
pretty far here i mean we have 8 000
votes in
i'll leave maybe do a revo at this point
no
yeah no no no i don't think so we got so
many to get through too we got to keep
this moving all right well i think i
think azazel's got it i think it's got
it it was close though very anonymous
jay
thank you so much what an incredible
submission
i thought for sure you'd be taking that
round but at zazzle
unbelievable
there's so much talent here
congratulations absolutely moving
forward
all right well next up we have jimmy tk
versus
gooney gunnardo i just love that name
all right well up first we have a video
actually a music video from jimmy tk
let's check it out ethan
i'm not sure why you have decided to
take it upon yourself and your show to
malign attack slander and defame maybe
it's because you're a huge [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
what's the difference between you and
ethan crime one successful business and
two dui's one punch
[Music]
middle fingers to the sky say it with me
one more time
[Music]
hold on i just want to say he said the
difference between us is a ponzi scheme
that's so that was retracted from his
business partner right i just want to
say that i had flashbacks of them
quoting this video you know i just
wanted to for the record i paused it and
corrected the record on that one i'm
gonna go back though i don't want to win
one successful business and two duis one
ponzi scheme and a bed for
[Music]
ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein.com
[Applause]
wow that was fun that was a great
kind of old-school laid-back vibe to it
i love that one jimmy tk loved the video
loved the vibe
i just had a lot of fun watching that
yeah and again the talent is
unbelievable i'm so impressed you guys
we got to do more
like user-generated
competitions like that we've done this a
few times in the past and it's always
been
total unbelievable total just win after
win from the audience so i mean
wow jimmy tk up next against jimmy tk is
gooney gunnardo dan's been looking
forward to this one i just like the name
also uh just coming out the gate loving
what i'm seeing on his face looks like
some herpes sores
some yellow teeth nose hairs loving the
whole thing
that being said gooney gennardo don't
sue me
you [ __ ] you litigious [ __ ] you piece of
[ __ ]
no one wanted to do this but now we have
to
so
why don't you sit tight you yellow tooth
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
drive angry too much wine variety said
you committed some crimes bad jewish
[ __ ] is your [ __ ] demise your
favorite place is between slides guess
what ryan you're ethan's [ __ ] he's a
monogamous now have his kids live in his
pool house he'll be a daddy as long as
you watch your back with their feet soon
everybody with daddy's money clean rats
come off life he's tummy lost a billion
just like a dummy doesn't matter when
it's not your money triller l marriage l
what about the lawsuits [ __ ] l one
star ryan failing again trailer was
flipped and i told all my friends you
look like harvey wearing depends gangnam
dick don't even pretend [ __ ] ass ryan
got publicly [ __ ] sucking your mouth
even dick in your guts nick on a leash
you are his [ __ ] pull down your pants
i'ma throw stairs shrimp
he won't jerk you off but maybe steve
will do it
[Music]
super fun appreciated the editing and
the subtitles that stuff's cool yeah but
all in all both
again
powerful competitors
had a ton of fun watching both of those
goony dinardo
incredible
jimmy tk i thank you both so so much for
submitting
and everyone's saying uh gooney sounded
like donkey i know i thought that too
i don't think it is dunky though but
that'd be awesome if it is all right the
pole is up and the
first round of votes have gooney in the
lead
see where this goes
two excellent competitors i just want to
thank them both again
incredible stuff here guys thank you so
much
for taking the time
and putting your talent into this
means so much to me to see all these
incredible super troopers out here
it looks like we can pretty much call
this one
it looks like goonies got it yeah goony
again jimmy tk
we loved you i had so much fun with your
video
uh but gooney dinardo is taking a
substantial lead it seems like a 63
percent
for gooney gunnardo
all right
thank you though we're calling it
i hope the runners up feel excellent
because there's not a single
bad performance in here i mean these are
again it was like 200 submissions
if you're on this bracket we liked it a
lot you know what i mean for it to even
get this far so
wow
wow um
all right
next matchup um actually i know because
i remember uh
we're gonna
get out of um
the rap game a little bit here is this
alternative we have some we have we'll
see you'll see
this one really cracked up so in this uh
category we have dirt mouth versus joe
sanders that's right so up first let's
see what dirt mouth has for us
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been watching for a minute my
friend just waited for the opportunity
to chime in godfather doesn't put up the
hit then i'm in no variety no sobriety
hope that i could be close to finally
noticed by the team open-mindedly wrote
the finest thing both your eyes are seen
but you wanna [ __ ] with a toy podcast
act like a dick put your boy on blast
temple in saudi never gonna get cash
rather than pour away your wifey
wings that you got sued for that's my
anchoring anchoring dumb [ __ ] like you
where the thing came to bring the heat
but knock off weinstein
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i said ryan
this is what you're writing
right you just [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Music]
but you don't follow love you know what
i'm saying
that [ __ ] make me feel like flipping out
[Music]
like i said these these next two both
have a different vibe than
pull up the uh
uh let me get the bracket back up yeah
the bracket um that was just an
incredible
unreal man death metal
that's the kind of song i could just get
drunk and crash into a
private car with you know just get you
that kind of amped up yeah wet and
reckless baby wow
wow dirt mouth
right now
what do you call that like heavy metal
death rock metal core slipknot as kind
of corny you know
well come on they're don't know corn
like the band
corn i'm just kidding
no it's like industrial rap or something
like that i would say industrial metal
kind of that's real and terra vibe
because he did rap
what does industrial mean industrial is
just generally it's kind of a i would
guess a fusion between
metal and
sort of
electronic but why do they call it
industrial just makes me think of it
like in a big empty warehouse that's
exactly because that's usually where the
parties where they would play the that
type of thing like hitting a metal
[ __ ] bar yeah against concrete hmm
people call it cav cav core yeah
well cap core
dirt mouth loved the uh very creative
approach certainly not
a song i expected to listen but i loved
it it was expected to hear
so that's awesome up next it sounds like
we have another unusual
submission from joe
sanders let's take a listen
[Music]
mine eyes have seen the glory of the
victory of h3 they have bit by bit
unraveled the pyramid scheme
of a small pathetic man who looks just
like harvey weinstein yeah just for the
record no pyramid scheme uh we were we
didn't accuse him of that
nobody's accused him of doing a pyramid
scheme right they well somebody did
in court but then they later retracted
it which variety updated their that's
what would be a ponzi
oh right ponzi what ponzi and are those
interchangeable terms i don't think so
ponzi is like when you take
money from one investor to pay off the
other one
right i guess there are more
okay but yeah i just want to make that
clear thank you i'm going to go back i
don't want to screw you over joe sanders
we're just trying to
keep these uh songs out of uh
official exhibits
thank
the
you
scheme
of a small pathetic man who looks just
like harvey weinstein his [ __ ] is
flipped on my screen
ryan cavanaugh
but ryan
i've seen him on the instagram talking
all kinds of [ __ ] deleting comments left
and right what a massive hypocrite
filing motion after motion just to see
what would stick
but in the end the victor was justice
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
but
[Music]
gorgeous
what a
beautiful like a patriotic kind of
god bless america thing okay it's the
battle hymn of the family said uh
somebody in the chat i mean these two
genres of music couldn't be different
you have
death metal or industrial metal yeah
whatever the [ __ ] that is
first uh
sweet home alabama
say it's a it's a rendition of a folk
song
what song is that i say battle hymn of
the republic
[Music]
all right i am going to throw up the
pole on this one
i am completely torn personally i don't
know who to vote for
incredible talents both and all
just honored to be
on the receiving end of such incredible
talent from all of you incredible
right competitive is up
and the first the first dump has come
out i really need to think about who to
vote for him
dumps i'm just trying to think so the
first guy was
metal
which i loved
it's like almost country
had some great moments in there
gee whiz man
gee willockers
sam was having a little hoedown back
here oh yeah did it remind you of home
yeah it was a vibe i loved it
getting them grits
well
sorry to tell you sam
dirk mouth the industrial rocker
is in a commanding lead it looks like
it's going to be dirt mouth 75 dirt
mouth
joe sanders you are
an absolute rock and roll legend a folk
legend i would say even
and uh we'll never forget you for your
submission
thank you so much
well there we have basically our first
bracket the first half is over with we
now are going to shift on over now i'm a
little bit confused how should we
proceed because we've heard all there
should we just play
a little
excerpt for the semifinals
when we get to the semis yeah just to
kind of remind people which one is which
we don't have to listen to them all all
the way through again
um but we haven't heard any of these yet
so we have a whole another bracket my
friend yes sir
up next is sean
rickard
with the song we like to call
little cav cav
ila donated ten dollars and said
everyone's so talented with teary eyes
yeah the tears in her eyes
you all are
i know
not worthy you guys keep going there and
do great things you all are amazing here
we go sean rickert
[ __ ] you ryan i can see right through
your yellow teeth you're lying like a
[ __ ] you tried to play it off like you
were always confident but now you're
rolling two in lawsuits and i think you
should admit that you're feeling just
like triller cause the [ __ ] script is
flipped [ __ ] always claiming that
you're rich but now you're rolling 60k
and digging deeper in your ditch ethan
klein can get in line because you're
such a [ __ ] stiff and he knows he
won't see a dime cause your businesses
are [ __ ] you try to wage a war on sites
like wikipedia the only thing you
brought down was relativity media you've
been caught hoe act like you did not
know you're just a one-stop [ __ ]
with a tick-tock clone
how does it feel to be laughed at
oh how does it feel
to be slapped back it's not that bad
little calf cap you're the one
being laughed at
and now there's no way
you can backtrack it's not that bad
little cat calf
you're running ponzi schemes and
skipping out on charities
yeah uh retracted yeah just to say
he was he was accused of such
by his ex-business partner was later
retracted
even though he did sign under a
penalty of perjury
uh
but uh you know but anyway uh not to
take away from performance sean rickard
uh i'm loving it by the way
you're running ponzi schemes and
skipping out on charity you're dressing
like you're 12. it's super [ __ ]
embarrassing hanging out with teens
cause you think it makes you cool while
your wife is getting pounded every night
by brad the bull crying like a [ __ ] and
saying you've been to fang but your own
reputation is the only one to blame
you're a [ __ ] staying late on humankind
but i guess that we can chalk that up to
too much wine you're taking all the l's
the most elves historically cause
everything i've said it's been said
reportedly you're coming for the best i
don't think you can afford to be so do
us all a favor and govern yourself
accordingly [ __ ]
wow
i'm loving that that's ryan kavanagh the
musical on broadway soon
love that you know the theater
performance just incredible the skill to
play the piano sing the song i love this
little contraption he's got here is this
an official contraption or like a
i think that's his mic stand is that a
real mic stand or just something he
macgyvered it looks like something in
macgyver which is badass yeah it's
badass
uh but wow olivia what do you think
about that as resident theater kid
wonderful
really really great
i won't say anymore yeah i'm i'm getting
i'm feeling hamilton vibes i'm ready for
deathcap the musical
i love it sean rickerts wow
super impressive my goodness thank you
so
all right you know whenever i hear the
first one i go man there's no way that
someone is gonna beat that and then they
come out we'll see we'll see all right
so
up next is jake
and fucino
pusino something like that
well
jake you're up against some some stiff
competition let's see what you got buddy
[Music]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is split bro at the
podium you talking on your tiptoes you
gon need a poop a scooper for this [ __ ]
bro cause every [ __ ] poopa troopa in
them snow
little [ __ ] you lost
you [ __ ] with a hairline boss
don't check with jimmy lee's running
through your house it's like relativity
this shit's
[Music]
vape nation [ __ ] and you don't really
want to smoke
[Music]
[Music]
all night every week in it he don't mean
any harm just talking one day with
trisha but now you said the militia
cause we confusing your picture with
harvey weinstein you in the basement
drink a guinness with your god kim you
probably should have seen the dentist
for your live stream but i just took
your wife to bed and breakfast get to
crying i'll prep the wedding regular
since i know you're gonna be driving
[Music]
can't
stand myself accordingly
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't know what to say it's just these
people are incredible that was so good
and now to be honest i'm porn
i don't know who to vote for another two
very different styles obviously both
excellent in their own respects uh i
don't know where this is gonna go i'm
gonna throw up a poll though here we go
i mean sean rickard was just incredible
the skill their performance
but jake came out so hard
an incredibly well produced track
great rhymes the rhymes were amazing the
flow was amazing the guys are talent
i am so torn you guys golly
i don't know who to vote for i really
i'm stumped
this is the first one i haven't voted
because i don't think i can pick you're
abstaining
from this one i just don't know who to
pick
oh [ __ ]
well actually it doesn't seem that it's
ending up to be very close
i see a lot of chat saying they're both
so good they were but it does seem like
the vote is leaning heavily one
direction right now yeah jake
uh in facino
with those savage savage
beasts
the lines the bars he delivered too
[ __ ] hard man
he's taken the w 67
jake and cucino
sean ricker i want to give a special
shout out to you dude
what a talent man he knew his audience
he played to it he played to his
strengths yeah i know he was trying to
get he was trying to bait me
sean ricker man
you have a bright future ahead of you
man just keep going talent
but uh jake advances calling it moving
jacob god lee next round here we go
i surpassed my expectations i told we
told you now are we able to get um
are we able to getting these people on
the phone like the head-to-head i'd like
to talk to or the winner especially get
them on the phone here
afternoon i mean yeah they they emailed
these all so we we have a concert
well
if you guys are you could they got to be
watching right now sure
guys watching we're going to get some of
y'all to call in so be by your phones if
you'd like to
but up next the next bracket we've got
grass kingdoms
versus suki alright guys
let's hear him
let me tell you about this guy named
brian
he is a dick
he's got a stupid app it's now worth
trying the cameras flip
[Music]
he's known to have a business plan
shaped like a pyramid
[Music]
nobody will see scamming all these kids
and not paying them a single cent
sliding into demons
[Music]
[Music]
nobody
loved it man
that of course was a grass kingdom
loved uh you know the creativity the
green screen
i love seeing all of his movies getting
having rotten scores a little pitchy
on the course they're a little pitchy
but um
love it
otherwise
but it's not really about the pitch it's
about the
the swag and he's got swag
uh swag swag swag ela says she loves
when you cut to visuals
yeah
wow all right up next thank you grass
kingdoms for that uh incredible
submission up next is
suki
here we go
hey bro you ever heard of this ryan
cavanaugh dude
who
ryan cavanaugh ceo of triller
ain't that company bankrupt bro yeah
yeah and did you also know that he had a
nanny and he got sued by the nanny
because he didn't pay her and he also
tried to frame one of his employees of
sexual harassment so he wouldn't have to
pay a severance allegedly ryan kavanagh
biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take the money
that you owe me take a trip to panama
trying to bully on me boy i beat you in
the court of law i better get your butt
cheeks ready cause i'm sliding and i'm
wrong
back to back defamation to a no we gon
keep on winning cases ain't no sympathy
for foes we gon pop you like a saudi i
ain't talking diet coke vape nation
while we reppin we gon always want to
smoke and shout out to my homie and his
name is brad the bull when you pay my
money back i better have that [ __ ] in
full i just beat another op and now i'm
moving to the next i ain't never gonna
stop hdpot we the best and shout out to
the people that be jealous cause they
hate us shout out keemstar man hogs
never mind i ain't even gonna say that
leasing all these haters cause i always
get the payback hey bro
do me a favor real quick and take out
your laptop and look up this website
called
does ryan kavanagh look like harvey
weinstein.com and tell me what you see
hi bro i got you fam
i see two pictures of the same person
that's what i'm saying bro but it's not
they're just looking like this is a
public service announcement to avoid
confusion between two straggling with
the
when you try to sue me [ __ ] i thought it
was a flashback boy you really cringey i
think i need me a hazmat i ain't talking
register but you gonna give me cash back
log into the trilla app and that's your
trash as hell boy your [ __ ] is off live
and i ain't talking heads or tails when
it comes to throws identity i'm never
gonna tell [ __ ] the odds that really
thought that i'd be rotting in a cell
rocking teddy fresh and i'd be dripping
in the sauce and i'm married to a baddie
either klein is she a boss you can sue
me all you want i ain't worried about
the cause i've been winning all these
lawsuits i don't ever take a loss and
you hella ugly and you look like harvey
weinstein yellow ass teeth boy you ain't
got no hygiene coming with the heat boy
i ain't talking dry clean when this song
is over imma leave it like a crime scene
ryan kavanagh biggest [ __ ] i ever saw
take the money that you owe me take a
trip to panama trying to bully on me boy
i beat you in the court of law i better
get your budgies ready cause i'm sliding
in the raw beat the cases back to back
defamation to a no we gon keep on
winning cases ain't no sympathy for foes
we gonna pop you like a sodium i ain't
talking diet coke vape nation while we
reppin we gon always want to smoke
and you heard that [ __ ] we gonna pop
you like a beach ball boy shout out gary
klein shout out donald little ball [ __ ]
and save the monarchs bro save the
[ __ ] monarchs bro
this ryan kavanaugh dude seems like a
real jerk
you know what i'm glad that i could
educate you bro cause he is he's a jerk
and and while i have you
why don't you why don't you get your
laptop out again and look up you ever
heard of howie mando
type in your computer right now howie
mandel tick tock and let me know what
you see
okay bro
h o
w i
what the [ __ ]
wow
from sukkah or sukiya
that was that was a whole journey man
suki came out super hard with that i
loved it
good flow loved the sketches
that was fun lots of shout outs
gary klein donna klein even got shout
outs
oh wow
well this one's a blowout
wow i listen
grass kingdoms don't feel bad
you [ __ ] crushed it that video
had swag
it was super entertaining
and i love you for making it all that
being said suki it took it down with 91
percent
which is an astounding blowout let's be
honest but
but
grass kingdoms swag for days
we love that for you wow
all right so sookie was a lore king man
that guy has
yeah his finger on the pulse
so we have one more semi-final
bracket to figure out here all right or
quarter final i always get confused i
guess it's quarterfinal isn't it
um yeah that idea okay here we go up
next is grid
verse
the evil eye effect
here we go guys here comes grid
nope that's the other okay here comes
grid
hey bro you ever heard of this ryan
cavanaugh that's the same song
uh-oh
i think we have a technical technical
issue with grid's song
that's definitely the same song okay uh
why don't you just go to the next one
we'll try and figure out what happened
with grid um
okay it's grid govern yourself
accordingly right yeah
yeah so the net we'll play his
competitor first and come back to grid
company bankrupt yeah that is the same
thing huh
okay
uh we'll we'll work on figuring that out
and yeah in the meantime let's do the
evil eye effect all right up next is um
the evil eye effect by
evil eye effect here we go lil calf cap
hey
[Music]
let me tell you
[Music]
he asked if you could maybe swallow it
all [ __ ] and you know you like the
disappointment to the idiots who
downloaded it no offense the only
offense is your stench all the lies you
produce and the lawsuits you lose what a
[ __ ]
and take what he can get free
babysitting debts investments it's all
his he don't have to pay he couldn't
anyway don't have any more money cause
he threw it all away hey don't be conned
by this liar his existence is scam he
lives in a state of perpetual denial
[Music]
hey big man
[Music]
hello caster
[Music]
mother
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh it's solo
a guitar solo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mr kavanaugh you have no balls wanted to
employ me that the h3 cards they all
said to tell you go [ __ ] yourself you
most of the lawsuits now slither back to
hell
we know your obsession with ethan and
his [ __ ] has overpowered all your common
sense which you never had one and by the
way even wanted to know when you file
for personal bankruptcy can he have your
vote sorry to temple this on you but
really i'm not i wanted to give you my
two week notice today here on the spot i
[ __ ] hate you harvey i mean cavi i
get so confused between the two those
hideous sobering warthogs
seriously though i'm so glad i don't
have to say me too to either one of
these low-life disgusting piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] white ass [ __ ]
wow
what a journey that was that guitar show
was kind of legit zach what'd you think
that was amazing that was very that was
shreds
love the genre changing the solo was
amazing wow
i mean we covered so much ground in that
song uh so versatile so much talent my
goodness
so what i think olivia thinks she
figured it out what happened we're
getting that set up um in the meantime
why don't i just move grid down
no no no no no we can't [ __ ] with the
with the bracket
yeah we can alright we'll send it then
that's not legit dude all right
it is what it is it's the evil eye
versus grid who or that was the evil eye
that was the damn
and the instruments it was a whole live
band that [ __ ] took and it really went
on on a journey i mean it started as a
portis head song and then
wound up being having like a metal solo
and going [ __ ] crazy was that like
trip hop like to start off i would say
the beginning was trip hoppy yeah
oh it's called what now trip up trip hop
trip hop yeah okay
so we are waiting for the infamous grid
uh it sounds like they're still working
on it why why don't we just re-trigger
this we can come back to grid one sec
olivia can you just drop it up
the file is difficult to open so it only
lets you sometimes download it but it
doesn't let you play it off of
wi-fi well if dan can play it if dan can
open the cut my throats
we can't mess with the bracket dan
i'm telling you i don't think that that
[Music]
oh here i got it i got it it's in
discord okay all right
all right so this is the infamous do it
grid
here we go we got it
we got it yeah we're good okay all right
here we go grid
you messed with the wrong people
now it's time to pay up
i rep the foot soldiers so you know you
shouldn't [ __ ] with me we clap back
faster then you bankrupt a company now
pay your fees before we go and tank your
score and we defeat your weak when we
unite so govern yourself accordingly you
weasel try to take out your partner like
a hit man you're evil trying to get with
a young natalie portman take on ethan
you must be a special kind of fool go
cry yourself to sleep while your wife
gets [ __ ] by brad the bull who am i
even rapping against ryan looking like
harvey weinstein i can't even tell the
difference kev kev are malicious in and
you're ignorant so in h3 only guarantee
that you dug your grave even faster
you're not a harvey approved force of
nature you're a natural disaster what
kind of a whack-ass happens trailer most
of it's half-assed filler you don't even
know the first thing about a running
tech company so take a look in the
mirror i'm in one of us and he's the one
and cuz we'll step back and drop a body
quick you got your head shoved so far up
your ass no wonder your [ __ ] is flipped
you're more ugly and heinous than
howie's prolapse and anus will take your
article and frame and expose the way
you're defaming your ponzi scheme your
yellow teeth and driving drunk and
disorderly will never be as bad as going
against h3 and not governing yourself
accordingly
great uh just want to say
ponzi scheme was retracted by his
partner
right
just to be clear just the foot not there
on that one
that was awesome that was fun
gritty
my little gritty
also nice plug here at the end legend a
legend of the grid actually is what it
goes by okay grid i see you there
also the evil eye effect versus grid the
pole some great flow there uh coming in
they're hot
fast and hot
so we did it
yeah the evil eye was the
woman singer rock and roll grid was the
rapper
all right early lead for the evil eye
effect and i just want to say
this doesn't strike me as a surprise
because the evil eye was just this
cinematic
incredible masterpiece but grid
you were up against the best and i just
want to say loved your track i thought
you did awesome
but uh i don't i think this one we can
call
for the evil eye effect which we can
close this out seventy-four percent evil
eyes steady at that race here yeah
all right the evil effect
good job grid though and people are
spamming evil eyes in the
chat
apparently there's an evil eye wait
don't do that there was someone in here
that had it branded on their chest in a
cult no that was the spiral
all right the evil effect going up and
we have one last bracket and then we are
moving um
actually here i am trying to figure out
what's the deal with this [ __ ] swirl
what is this from kim true detective oh
okay i love that
oh was there a squirrel in there did you
add that that was yeah that was the
whole theme of the show too or i mean
like a big symbol on the show oh they
actually did the swirl next you know
that first
the first season of true detective was
so sick
probably best season of tv ever
i loved it i don't know why it's
probably the best season tv that's ever
been produced it was so good i loved the
whole like weird supernatural love it
yes but then they didn't really follow
that up in the in the coming seasons do
they do two or three seasons three three
seasons
i like them
i i like them but that first one was
just incredible but yeah okay the swirl
ladies and gentlemen we're trying to
figure out
what is up
with the swirl um
up next guys we our final bracket here
of the uh
semis
we have sergio
verse liquid fives here is sergio's
bloody rivers
[Music]
dear harvey weinstein i mean ryan
kavanagh got a couple facts for your
[ __ ] ass and this ain't capital mr
scheme pain even your partner jumps [ __ ]
try to sue me in hd get off a teddy
fresh take your dumb [ __ ] now aila is
the queen man that's my dude no matter
how hard you try you'll never join the
truth insanity stupidity we still can't
describe i guess you're just mad your
wife is real by brad a bull all the time
young buck said it best shawty wanna
ride you came for ethan klein now we let
the judge aside now you gotta pass
interest for our wasted time you dumb
[ __ ] idiot don't forget it's 100
i bet you cried in the car down that you
heard about sony you should have known
sooner or later we all know you're phony
what's your obsession with those do you
want him in your throat or arya maybe
you need part two for how you beat that
dui cav cav wet or reckless is that your
gay porn i'll give you one prime minute
never mind [ __ ] him carry on what now
did i hear kevin hearts on your app you
better get hard out of the laws on your
back but regardless of that whiner no
wine you are one sick [ __ ] you could be
the last man on earth and natalie
portman still wouldn't let you [ __ ] so
just mount up
you hear that [ __ ] face
how's this taste [ __ ]
stupid-ass idiot [ __ ] loser
yo that was fun yeah that was really i
loved it the flows
it was just great love the delivery
loved his voice the style everything wow
so much talent sergio yeah that was
sergio my man
surge
five this is the last one my boy serge
incredible incredible stuff man
well coming up next uh our final
uh challenger here at the
semis
is liquid five go flip yourself
let's listen
[Music]
the last song he said something about a
ponzi i forgot to say i'm gonna start it
over for you uh liquid five
last guy uh uh my boy sergio just want
to say
about the ponzi his partner retracted
the claim yeah later when later not
underwrote not on earth like when he
first made the claim
right but he did retract it
yep so anyway liquid five everybody
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
more of a relaxing experience kind of a
psychedelic synth wave synth wavy we
love that don't flip yourself indeed it
sounded like this band called ghost
they're they're gonna kind of vibe like
that really cool okay wow ghost uh
reminiscent of
all right so
this is the last uh bracket here on the
back end this is indeed so let's take
our vote and then we're gonna move
forward to the really nitty-gritty part
yep
the quarter-finals we're going to figure
out who is going to win this thing
this is going to be hard man i don't
know how we can possibly crown
oh we got a fairly close one so far and
the initial dumps
yeah taking a look uh they call them
dumps sergio is uh coming out initially
in the lead 61 percent
we'll give it a little bit of time
because it's relatively close here
[Music]
um not much movement i think we could
probably call it stayed at the same
percentages maybe give it one more shot
and then
oh another update oh sergio actually
went up in the next update so i think
sergio's got it liquid5 loved the synth
yeah it was a beautiful love the vibe
just beautiful
just beautiful
but sergio you came so hard man
congratulations on advancing so let's
open the bracket now and take a look yep
now we're in the
quarterfinals here guys
um
you just thought you just had a really
good stop
like sergio you came so hard
sorry
he did come so hard he came so hard yeah
so hard
so i don't know if we need to listen to
the whole song necessarily
or maybe we should
um
well no
i think we should do that it i think we
should
reassess them when we get uh closer to
the end like for the finals for sure we
should give them another full listen but
i think give them a minute let me get a
minute yeah let's let's give like a
refresher but yeah so so refreshing back
at the first uh
bracket here j fella
versus a zazzle a-z okay
this is the
quarterfinals or the semifinals really
so um i guess just go back in the
playlist uh
the top of it
yeah hold on i close that
so we're going to uh jay fella here he
is
so i got a call from my lawyers
yesterday with the great news
that
not only did we win or but we got a
hundred percent of the attorney's fees
[Music]
yo let me tell you a little story it's
sad but it's about your boy cab cabin
brad the boat my wife wants it every
night morning and afternoon i know she's
my wife but rather you can have it too
cause there's a few things i treasure in
life ponzi schemes zoo and ethan and
brad [ __ ] my wife bankrupting
companies and paying for likes and the
fun's ain't nothing [ __ ] it man i'm
suing them twice hey ryan what's for
breakfast
is if you didn't make enough of a first
impression they call them cut cuz up in
his first direction getting slandered in
the media at home in bed like dear
wikipedia like writing mean things that
ain't true but they really are plus
there's this guy named gross but don't
be alarmed
let's talk about paying your talent and
claiming bankruptcy and waving the
balance and by the way man shame on your
stylist that shit's foul someone said
it's the fallacy
so i'm going to stop it there it's a
minute
wow that one went hard i forgot one
first that way that one is yo that one's
insane
[Music]
jay fella
fila
wow
so up who's he up against here dan he is
up against uh azazel az
which if i recall was another one that
we were all very impressed with so this
is this is gonna be a tough bracket
here's a azazel a-z
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make a list all of the [ __ ] that
you did a coward on a power trip sour
from hours you spent on a business just
being
[Music]
was a ball and a best friend might be
your best investment everything else is
less than let's see relativity
relatively empty no hits in a century
ponzi is putting it lightly that's just
according to variety oh that reminds me
[Music]
we think it grosses so does natalie
portman
wow so it's hard to stop these i want to
listen to the whole thing again
unbelievable i mean
wow wow and this one's like three
minutes it was like a full track
the other way guys was was a little over
a minute but oh my god i mean who do you
vote for
so two heavyweights i'm lost on that one
this could easily be the championship
bracket yeah
golly
wow people say why not listen to the
whole thing it's just we have there's
another round after that for the
semi-finals and then the finals there's
just a lot to get through and we have
heard them all already on the finals
we'll listen to the whole yeah we'll
give it another listen
this is more to just refresh
um so the poll is up wow
and it looks
like jay bella is going to take this one
that's crazy dude
[Music]
unfortunately someone had to lose which
is insane because
just so good the both of them as zazzle
az you know
that was just
incredible man you're still proud
of that the further dumps keep coming in
and the percentages are staying steady
at 63 37. oh it actually just ticked up
one that's it's over for zazel but i
don't think he's closing that gap yeah
well jay phelp congratulations this is
this is big let's open the bracket
all right
so wow yeah i mean guys we still have a
lot
that's what i'm saying yeah i would love
to listen to them all again but this is
this is jfl advances we're getting we're
getting down to the nitty-gritty here
guys
that jay fella track is so hard
all right let's move you're asking uh
are you posting these yeah i think we'll
we'll post uh either a playlist or maybe
even just in the past we've made like
one video that's a all of the emptys
um
for a lot of our like song competition
so we'll do we'll do one of those two
and you'll be able to hear all these or
each one individually you think is too
much
we could do that too do both order mega
we can just do a mega one and then we'll
timestamp
yeah that's how we've done it in the
past yeah
it's an album really that's another one
yeah
all right sorry up next is goonie yeah
let's give a goonie dinardo another
listen my boy gooney
you [ __ ] you litigious [ __ ] you piece of
[ __ ]
no one wanted to do this but now we have
to
so
once you sit tight you yellow tooth
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right
drive angry too much wine variety said
you committed some crimes bad jewish
[ __ ] cause you're [ __ ] the most your
favorite place is between two sides
guess what ryan hold on we gotta i just
gotta acknowledge he call he called he's
going after me a little bit
fat jewish cuck is your [ __ ] demise
okay but i take it you know and then the
cro everyone gets caught in the
crossfire in war right wait did he say
cox
[ __ ]
oh he said ethan's yeah jewish [ __ ] yes
oh i thought you called me a [ __ ] no no
that's the first time everyone said i
had a fat jewish [ __ ]
tiny to it
oh thanks bro gooney's my man
[Music]
drive angry too much wine variety said
you committed some crimes bad jewish
[ __ ] cause you're [ __ ] the most your
favorite place is between the east sides
guess what ryan you're ethan's [ __ ]
he's a monogamous now i have his kids
leaving his pool house he'll be a daddy
as long as you watch your back with
their feet strewn everybody with daddy's
money clean brad's come off wifey's
tummy lost a billion just like a dummy
doesn't matter when it's not your money
trailer l marriage l what about the
lawsuit's [ __ ] l one star ryan
failing again trailer was flipped and i
told all my friends you look like harvey
wearing depends gangrene dick don't even
pretend [ __ ] ass ryan got publicly
[ __ ] sucking your mouths dick in your
guts neck on a leash you are his [ __ ]
pull down your pants i'ma throw stairs
shrimp what's up cuck you out here
[ __ ] [ __ ] i doubt now get to sucking
spoiled rich kid little ass dick all
right so there you go again i it just
feels it feels horrible to pause things
in but yeah we're just trying to refresh
here
gooney gunnardo
going up against dirt mouth
dirt mouth like smash mouth
this was the epic uh it was the uh
industrial industrial one yeah here is
dirtmouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] be prepared
i've been watching for a minute my
friend just waited for the opportunity
to chime in godfather doesn't put out
the hit then i'm in no variety no
sobriety hope that i could be close to
finally noticed by the team
open-mindedly wrote the finest thing
both your eyes are seen but you wanna
[ __ ] with a toy podcast act like a date
put
[Music]
that's it that's again
wow
damn you know what it sounds like it
sounds like that band of ministry are
you familiar with them sure i know
ministries yeah it's actually thinking
mindless self-indulgence oh if anybody
remembers them
well there's older millennials out there
once again
two powerhouses here going up against
each other
janet you gotta pull up the uh
bracket for me please
and the pole is up
gooney gunnardo
verse dirt mouth ladies and gentlemen
the wrap
versus the uh
industrial rock apparently
[Music]
both so good man oh my god it's so hard
to decide but
i thought gooney he did such a good
delivery and
i liked his flow a lot
but it looks like dirt mouth
with the incredible
production value full on
you know rock and roll performance
is taking a massive lead here 78 for
dirt mouth so
[Music]
like
they're clinching it gooney you know you
are the man you are the man thank you so
much but congratulations
to dirk now
wow why don't we do them and see who
goes to the finals since we already it's
all fresh oh interesting yeah okay
um but then so so jay fella versus dur
mouth
so i kind of want to listen to the whole
song yeah i mean so maybe we should go
back then so it's fresh
do the other side
okay
so going on to jake and suki then
this is so stiff you guys
jake
and foose uh
and fusino versus all right
here's jake
and fusino
[Music]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] is split bro
at the podium you talking on your
tiptoes you gon need a poop a scooper
for this [ __ ] bro cause every [ __ ]
pooper trooper in them snow
[Music]
it's like relativity this shit's about
to cost like carrying the bleachers
cece's coming through your boss
[Music]
can't
[Music]
you dm me eating like it's all night
every weekend and he don't mean any harm
just talking one day with trisha but now
you said the militia cause we confusing
your picture with harvey weinstein you
in the basement drink a guinness with
your god kim
all right
by the way shout out to ian for the
incredible visuals yeah
thanks wonderful workout loving the work
back there also just real quick but
azazel donated ten dollars oh he's in
the audience said a shout out to jay
fella and shout out to the chat this was
a trip check out ryan abeesh streaming
on all platforms now so if you're
selling fun so there you go ryan a [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen man thank you
azazil yeah you are a absolute legend
all right so that was uh that was a jake
right
that was you yes yes and so now we're
gonna listen to suki
so all right coming up next
let's see here sookie all right
hey bro you ever heard of this ryan
cavanaugh dude
who
ryan cavanaugh ceo of triller
ain't that company bankrupt bro yeah
yeah and did you also know that he had a
nanny and he got sued by the nanny
because he didn't pay her and he also
tried to frame one of his employees of
sexual harassment so he wouldn't have to
pay a severance allegedly ryan cavanaugh
biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take the money
that you owe me take a trip to panama
trying to bully on me boy i beat you in
the court of law better get your butt
cheeks ready cause i'm sliding and i'm
raw beat the cases back to back
deformation to a no we gon keep on
winning cases ain't no sympathy for foes
we gonna pop you like a saudi i ain't
talking diet coke vape
shout out to my homie and his name is
brad the bull when you pay my money back
i better have that [ __ ] in full i just
beat another op and now i'm moving to
the next i ain't never gonna stop hdpark
we the best and shout out to the people
that be jealous cause they hate us shout
out keemstar matt haas trisha
never mind i ain't even gonna say that
that's a great moment oh man flow's
impeccable
i love that they like
it's a good one man so jake
infusino versus suki throwing up the
pole
right now i have no idea this is so hard
how do you involve
i haven't got a clue
it's unfair to ask our audience to have
to make these calls wait who jake i
gotta hear jakes again i like
i'm just gonna zap it real fast
[Music]
man they're both so good
yeah it's a it's a close one here
and you know it's a shame to ask you
guys to vo to to even have someone lose
in the face of such raw talent but
suzuki is in the lead i feel like i'm
seeing jake in the chat like the jake
fans are very powerful and they're loud
but the votes they're leaning sookie
yeah i mean suki is definitely winning
you're 63 if you all love jake so much
you better click that button
because
[Music]
how is yeah there's lots of support for
jake interesting
but i'm i'm getting ready to call it i
mean
yeah
it's a 20 point spread
[Music]
people are saying jake was robbed lots
well jake lots of love for you even
though you lost you won the hearts for
people it seems like
i'm sorry shout out tsuki but i i i've
i'm jake man you're jk i'm jk you're not
alone man everybody's screaming jake
yeah
but but still congrats sookie i mean
jake it's creeping up it's still a long
ways to go though it's still i'm just
disappointed
i like to get long i like suki a lot too
i'm not even gonna vlog because i love
them all so i love them all they're all
like like my children
i couldn't possibly say i love one more
thing
i let the people vote uh well
congratulations suki you are advancing
the people love you jake the people love
you
all right so one last quarterfinal
uh the evil eye effect versus
sergio this is a tough one
their evil eye was that whole adventure
[Music]
let's listen to evil eye
hey
[Music]
nobody likes you
are you stupid ass [ __ ] boy
hey
i'm not a cat cat
nobody likes you
ain't nothing but a little punk [ __ ]
boy mr kavanagh you have a call it's
from ethan klein telling you to suck his
paws
he asked if you could maybe swallow it
all [ __ ] and you know you like the
ticking you know you like that you tick
heard you had an app called truly that
[ __ ] was split disappointment to the
idiots who downloaded it no offense the
only offense is your stench all the lies
you produce and the lawsuits you lose
now i'm gonna skip forward now i'm gonna
say
yeah there's such a different ending to
it that might skip around a little bit
here because it's long and i want you
guys to hear the whole thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go you guys that's the evil
eye effect the whole journey
bad [ __ ] ass man yeah badass shredder
oh those are the ones that had that
badass guitar badass solo
actually if i could find it i play
pretty good
it's gotta be somewhere around here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's like a symphony there's movements
there's different movements that all
have its own vibe
so
uh
up next against the evil eye effect is
the one and only sergio
[Music]
[Music]
harvey weinstein i mean ryan kavanagh
got a couple facts for your [ __ ] ass
and this ain't capital mr ponzi's game
faint even your partner jumps [ __ ] try
to sue me in hd get off a teddy fresh
dick y'all dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
no matter how hard you try you'll never
join the truth insanity stupidity we
still can't decide i guess you're just
mad your wife is real by rather bull all
the time young buck said it best shorty
wanna ride you came for ethan klein now
we let the judges aside now you gotta
pass interest for our wasted time you
dumb [ __ ] idiot don't forget it's 100
i bet you cried in the car now that you
heard about sony you shoulda known
sooner or later we all know you're phony
there you go that's sergio barzerio
barnes and bars and great delivery love
the style i mean sergio is he's a world
class
is this just gonna get harder
and harder folks this is not gonna get
easier
no
sir it's not easy so
no it's not thank you lance stewart
that's an old fallback
you know this is such a hard one and
they're so different they're so
different those are always the most
difficult when the genres don't match up
how do you really get your get your
votes in people
if you're passionate
don't let this turn into another what
was the guy's name kevin
don't let us turn into another jake
situation
[Music]
uh-oh
well
i think that's uh we're calling it yeah
sergio
man i love yours but
the evil eye is taking the vote 65 35
you know there's just too much going on
there
so the evil advances
uh and sergio you are still a king
all right
moving
the evil eye into
the semis there we are okay so from here
i think
let's just get a little refresher again
because i feel like
we'll listen to the full songs on the
final or you guys want to hear the full
songs here
just not sure
i think a refresher is fine yeah that's
what i'm feeling i think full songs for
the fun so jay
fella back at the top where it all began
a reflex i'm gonna start halfway because
listen the first half oh that's there
you go the last yeah
listen to the back half of these oh jay
fella is missing
did you get her right at the top
okay there you go
so i'm gonna go i got a call from my
lord man i'm suing him twice hey ryan
what's for breakfast a weapon recklessly
so i'm a third time i haven't learned my
lesson is if you didn't make enough of a
first impression they call them cut cuz
up in his first direction getting
slandered in the media at home in bed
like dear wikipedia they writing mean
things that ain't true but they really
are plus there's this guy named gross
but don't be alarmed
let's talk about paying your talent the
claim of bankruptcy and waving the
balance and by the way man shame on your
status that shit's foul someone say it's
the phallus you're 47 why you dressed so
childish trailers things flip fees of
delinquent and don't get me started and
why your jeans got sequence you're a
[ __ ] millionaire get your teeth fixed
can't even pay a nanny man that kevi's a
cheap [ __ ]
[Music]
so there you go there you go i gotta say
jay fellas still goes so hard
and he is up against
dirt dirt mouth which is another one
that people are very passionate about
this is
this is gonna be a tough one here's dirt
mouth guys
let's start halfway saying you wanna
[ __ ] with the toy podcast act like a
dick put your boy on blast temple in it
so they never gotta get cash rather for
where your wifey yet set us up one of
them triangle rings that you got sued
for that's my anchoring angering dumb
[Music]
you just [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so yeah that was the industrial rock i
mean that one is a fan favorite for sure
both of these guys are fan favorites
both great i mean we're in we're in the
semis now all of these have won multiple
times at this point
it's gonna be tough these could easily
be the final round here easily um but
these two
brave competitors have found themselves
head to head here
so it is for us to decide
is it jay fella
or dirt mouth
here we go the rapper the hip hop first
the rock
god lee this is out of the gate closest
closest poll yet
get your votes in guys this matters
yeah we're closer it's 42.58 in favor of
dirt mouth but it's it's narrowing 44.
[Music]
get your votes in guys
j fella fans get your votes in
your mouth too
and doorbell too
[Music]
it's narrowing
this is too important to call early so
okay j fellas at 45 percent dirt now 55
percent guys get it in
[Music]
oh another narrow
we only have 54.
we only have 6 000 votes so
[Music]
there's a lot of you out there 446
that's my number that could tip this
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i spilled rubbing testing
everywhere
have you just been sipping on that the
whole time yeah it's little sips my
throat is really [ __ ] up like not like
i'm in coding or anything no no it's
okay it's just funny
oh another notch oh man guys we gotta
let this one play out i'm just saying
there's 7 000 votes
there's a lot of you out there that have
not voted
[Music]
guys there's 36 000 people watching
get your votes in
[Music]
do it do it
almost 8 000
do it do it
47 j dilla to 53 dirt mouth
jay fella you keep calling him j dilla
oh that's a real yeah that's nice jay
fella sorry
my boy jay fellow
um
i'm gonna have to call this if you guys
don't get out there voting
we're at eight thousand votes maybe when
it hits ten thousand
we'll say
no more
we should be in like one or two more
updates here yeah by the way as you guys
vote
we're planning on doing a metaverse
episode tomorrow but i don't think i
think i need to oh your throat right so
we can have a show on friday because my
throat is mega [ __ ] dude uh abs asking
if you want a beef stick what you got
what kind of beef stick you know what
kind
are those good i saw those laying around
i do why do you think they'll offer me
i'm just curious
all right it seems to have
as i was saying that
5248 thank you bro
thank you baby hey b taiwan eb with the
meat sticks coming through yeah i um
i've been trying to open this for five
minutes
and i yelled out
and she showed up out of nowhere and
we've been trying to open this for five
minutes we got to open
it tastes like jerky
the joy god bless tastes like beef jerky
thank you baby that's a good meat stick
is that from your childhood butcher
[Applause]
no no this is from walmart okay
it's just worthless that's my childhood
the momentum just shifted
uh dirt mouth action hold on hold on
hold on
go ahead zach
i felt worthless no the the best one i
felt gay again okay go ahead dad
all right dirt mouth it had been closing
in fellas direction but it just ticked
back up for dirt mouth i and we're at
9290 votes oh wait no now it's back to
5248. we got to call it guys
yeah yeah it's dumb this was listen
obviously it was so close this was our
closest one yet and these guys are but
i thought jay fella was gonna have a
real shot at the
finals here
and boy was he close 48
jay fellow
losing to the incredible i'm giving it
one more update just because if if it
goes 51.49 i feel like we got to let it
play out but
okay it just updated it's still 52.48
that's it dirt mouth
52 percent
dirt mouth away
i i hate to call it but man
we could sit here all day
maybe we should do a revo when it's that
close don't think that's more fair in my
opinion i'll be here forever man
oh lena can you get something to help me
clean up this
robot test clean
okay we have our first finalist
dirt mountain finalist dirt mouth
right on ryan's dirty mouth you know
what i just realized we said prizes for
first second and third yeah we have to
do a fourth place do we have to do a
oh or we just why don't we just give it
yeah a prize to fourth grade
okay i was going to say like a loser's
bracket but
no just gets better yeah i'll just give
each of them a hundred bucks right three
and four
which is kind of the same placing yeah i
felt game
yeah yeah
can you play that during pride a minute
so absolutely yeah
all right so we have suki versus the
evil eye effect
oh man this is really coming down to it
okay
here we go
i'm gonna skip ahead here
and that's your trash as hell boy your
[ __ ] is off live then i ain't talking
heads or tails when it comes to throws
identity i'm never gonna tell [ __ ] the
ops that really thought that i'd be
riding in a cell rockin teddy fresh and
i be drippin in the sauce and i'm
married to a baddie either kline and she
a boss you could sue me all you want i
ain't worried about the cause i've been
winning all these lawsuits i don't ever
take a loss and you hella ugly and you
look like harvey weinstein yellow ass
teeth boy you ain't got no hygiene
coming with the heat boy i ain't talking
dry clean when this song is over imma
leave it like a crime scene ryan
kavanagh biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take
the money that you owe me take a trip to
panama trying to bully on me boy i beat
you in the court of law i better get
your budgies ready cause i'm sliding
into raw beat the cases back to back
defamation
is so good i mean fire
just fire that 808 it's hard it does it
hits so hard that's suki ladies and
gentlemen
and the next one
which is interesting is the um
the evil eye right and and they're also
a very
um unusual submission much like the
winner of the last bracket
um
so this could turn out a really
interesting matchup but let's see one
more time the evil eye i'll just play
the back of it thank you lina
go ahead the you the evil eye ladies and
gentlemen go ahead
here we go
[Music]
mr kavanaugh you have no bonds
wanted to employ me that the h3
they all said to tell you go [ __ ]
yourself
the most of the lawsuits now slither
back to hell
we know your obsession with ethan and
his [ __ ] has overpowered all your common
sense which you never have
and by the way ethan wanted to know when
you file for personal bankruptcy can he
have your vote sorry to temple this on
you but really i'm not i wanted to give
you my two week notice today here on the
spot i [ __ ] hate you harvey i mean
cathy i get so confused between the two
those hideous sobering warthogs
seriously though i'm so glad i don't
have to say me too to either one of
these low-life disgusting piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] wife once again
evil eye was the
journey
that's yep spoken word
so this is it guys
all right the
clip
or i'm sorry the poll is going up here
we go
it all comes down to this
sookie
the hip-hop freestyle
versus evil live the
journey
[Music]
just a whole journey
and
you know evil eye was a fan favorite all
through this
smashing through the brackets
but it looks like they've met their
match here today suki the juggernaut is
cleaning up at 70 percent of the vote
what is this jimmy lee drop what is this
jimmy lee post it's
like he sent us
gemini is out of control man what is
this [ __ ]
this is a group chat with zach i and
some number i don't recognize
yeah he'll just add you to [ __ ] with
random people he'll call you with random
people on the phone ryan cavanaugh says
i love jimmy ware show ethan do it do it
do it
do it do it peer pressured into it yeah
or was he talking about the sound
do it
is he watching live oh it could be do it
he's probably watching jimmy what do you
want just post it on instagram
you want me to show every meme you make
there's like a thousand a day it's an
old timey meme
yeah this one is especially proud of
i could probably the only one he
understands
all the other ones are like deep fried
to oblivion
[Laughter]
all right suki
has clearly taken this
i'd love to see jimmy's sales numbers on
jimmy's where
you know i'm sure you'd share it with us
wait i want to see what he's doing just
text it again do it he said zach you got
lot rhythm do it gym where
jimmy you're so rich what could you
possibly stand the game from making like
five dollars on the shirt i'm very
curious what his numbers are
jimmy send zack your numbers i want to
see what what's
going back and who's the scenario
probably mason
mason doesn't exist mason doesn't exist
as well i'm convinced all right i'm sure
he does enough of that
this is it guys
the grand finale we're going to listen
to both songs in their entirety
this is the big one guys this is the big
one
i closed the uh
i closed the playlist again
dude these jake stands are still who are
you
no other
jacob no other fan base
has been unable to take the loss
jake stands there is it just a meme now
or is jake i think that's just i think
it's just jacob
all right suki here we go the whole damn
thing
this is it
hey bro you ever heard of this ryan
cavanaugh dude
who
ryan cavanaugh ceo of triller
ain't that company bankrupt bro yeah
yeah and did you also know that he had a
nanny and he got sued by the nanny
because he didn't pay her and he also
tried to frame one of his employees of
sexual harassment so he wouldn't have to
pay a severance allegedly ryan kavanagh
biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take the money
that you owe me take a trip to panama
trying to bully on me before i beat you
in before the law better get your butt
cheeks ready cause i'm sliding and i'm
raw beat the cases back to back
deformation to i know we gon keep on
winning cases ain't no sympathy for foes
we gonna pop you like a sodi i ain't
talking diet coke babe nation
and shout out to my homie and his name
is brad the bull when you pay my money
back i better have that [ __ ] in full i
just beat another op and now i'm moving
to the next i ain't never gonna stop hd
part we the best and shout out to the
people that be jealous cause they hate
us shout out keemstar matt haas trisha
nah never mind i ain't even gonna say
that leasing all these haters cause i
always get the payback hey bro
do me a favor real quick and take out
your laptop and look up this website
called
does ryan kavanagh look like
harveyweinstein.com and tell me what you
see hi bro i got you fam
i see two pictures of the same person
that's what i'm saying bro but it's not
it's just looking alike this is a public
service announcement to avoid confusion
between two struggling with the homie
zach and we smoking on this cat pack
when you try to sue me [ __ ] i thought it
was a flashback but you really cringey i
think i need me a hazmat i ain't talking
register but you gonna give me cash back
log into the trilla app and that's your
trash as hell boy your [ __ ] is off live
then i ain't talking heads or tails when
it comes to throws identity i'm never
gonna tell [ __ ] the ops i really thought
that i'd be rotting in a cell rock and
teddy fresh and i'd be dripping in a
sauce and i'm married to a baddie either
kline is she a boss you can sue me all
you want i ain't worried about the cause
i've been winning all these lawsuits i
don't ever take a loss and you hella
ugly and you look like harvey weinstein
yellow ass teeth boy you ain't got no
hygiene coming with the heat boy i ain't
talking dry clean when this song is over
imma leave it like a crime scene ryan
kavanagh biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take
the money that you owe me take a trip to
panama trying to bully on me boy i beat
you in the court of law i better get
your budgets ready cause i'm sliding
into raw beat the cases back to back
defamation to a no we gon keep on
winning cases ain't no sympathy for foes
we gonna pop you like a sodium i ain't
talking diet coke vape nation while we
reppin we gon always want to smoke
and you heard that [ __ ] we gon pop you
like a beach ball boy shout out gary
klein shout out donna glitter ball [ __ ]
tay trying to sue me to wait i've been
here before i think i'm having deja vu
hey
and save the monarchs bro save the
[ __ ] monarchs bro man this ryan
kavanagh dude seems like a real jerk
you know what i'm glad that i could
educate you bro because he is he's a
jerk and while i have you
why don't you why don't you get your
laptop out again and look up you ever
heard of howie mandel
type in your computer right now howie
mandel tick tock and let me know what
you see
okay bro
h o
w i
what the [ __ ]
there it is a whole the guy's got the
flow
galore
i mean it's a masterpiece suki
sorry i'm on the phone i had a little
family emergency but i listened the
whole thing okay
yeah it's not really
nothing to talk about here
everything's fine though uh
damn those beef sticks are killer bro
how many calories in one of those uh i
go check they're sliming yeah i know
it tastes like beef jerky you see little
[ __ ] you don't have to look i'll look
after you stop that you're [ __ ]
you want to grab me one by the way yeah
grab me one if you're up
i felt worthless
yeah what does you feel fizzy
i felt ugly
i felt worthless go on ugly i felt gay
i felt that no
like that is based on what they told me
oh my god that's my man fussy right
there
you saw my uh note about jimmy
oh yeah jimmy told us he made five
thousand dollars from jimmy ware what do
you guys think about that huh hey how
bad not bad what's the cows
per stick yeah oh my god
i can't 100 110 per stick i just kicked
down like 300 that's like 400 calories
wow that's impressive yeah it's all just
like beef fat inside
yeah
tastes like juicy
okay
i can't do that 110 per stick
that's not worth it for that little
juice it's not do it
all right well oh yeah jamie made five
grand what do you guys think about that
hey
you don't like it oh jack no i'm glad
he's thriving
it's just i
look i love jimmy and i know he's
watching right now my instagram feed is
just [ __ ]
yeah he's ruined my instagram facebook i
muted him it's it's it's [ __ ] up jimmy
i love you i'm happy you're selling
these shirts like seriously god bless
you my instagram feed is [ __ ] it's
totally [ __ ] it's just gone because he
posts like 10 rapid fire memes right
when i wake up in the morning zack you
know you can uh mute but i can't i i
have a muted and then i just came in
and i seen his latest post said he wants
to kill me
oh yeah kill star killers shout out oh
that was weird
i told him one more bed post i'm gonna
suggest that he's put in a
conservatorship
and he said all jokes
it's all joe it's an old-time joke he's
just i'm going to kill you he's just
having a good time
listen bro you made five grand at least
send us you got to send the missing
merch does he's got a he's got any
all right enough
suki is the man now the greatest
competitor dirt mouth
here we go this is the finals people did
we gotta hold a dirt mouth there oh no
no dirt mouth check your email dartmouth
if you're out there checking your email
all right here we go
you can't talk he's streaming right now
on corpse's channel
he's cleaning his mouth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
by then klein went for your hind end
i've been watching for a minute my
friend just waited for the opportunity
to chime in godfather doesn't put up the
hit then i'm in no variety no sobriety
hope that i could be close to finally
noticed by the team open-minded they
wrote the finest thing both your eyes
are seen but you wanna [ __ ] with a toy
podcast act like a dick put your boy on
blast template and slowly never gotta
get cash rather for where your wifey yet
set us up when eleven triangle rings
that you got sued for that's my
anchoring anchoring dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
you just [ __ ] up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for the same thing tell me how you gonna
follow love but you don't follow love
you know what i'm saying
that [ __ ] make me feel like flipping out
like trailer
what a talent
this guy's like a legit musical artist
a lot of these people are a lot of them
were
um
you know as we come down here on the
final vote don't throw it up yet dan oh
too late okay or whatever
as we come here on the final vote
i like to remember all the hard-fought
battles
all the incredible musicians that have
come here today
wow such talent thank you everybody
thank you so much
such an honor
for you guys to have made these for us
right now
it's maybe our closest one yet which i'm
happy to say
suki is in
uh a dirt mouth is in the lead by 53 so
it is very close 52 now
guys
get your vote in this is the oh it's 50
dollars it's 50 50 people it's 50 50
people
this is the
final event it is 50
50. this is incredible
just took the lead get your votes and
people your vote matters
suki just took the lead 51
your vote matters now guys
get the vote in for the person you love
do it it matters now more than ever
51
49 dirt mouth
this is just unbelievable thank you for
the gifted so proud of our so proud of
our family 50 gift this subs thank you
bro i'm so proud of you thank you so
much so proud of you
[Music]
guys get your vote in suki is now ahead
52 48
dirt mouth took the early lead suki has
turned it around 52 to 48 guys we have 8
500 votes in let's get in at least 12
thousand we have to know four thousand
more votes
we have to know get those votes in prime
give prime
give
right thank you for the gift
proud of our family thank you man thank
you to our that's got to be our saudi
prince right
uh it is i yeah yeah it is hey what by
the way can you guys turn back on the um
the gasoline production it's kind of
[ __ ] up my
stocks
he's on the saudis
they turn back on yeah wow lots of jokes
damages
get your camel it's an old timey joke
yeah talk to the oppac opec people
please thank you
get those votes in guys 9 000 in drives
an electric car by the way
yeah i don't care i just
i mean the world is suffering we need
gas you know in germany they can't even
they can't even heat their houses they
got no [ __ ]
they got no energy
don't you care about the germans dan
germans did a few things to my people so
i don't you still holding that on hold
on to that i'm kidding it's time to let
it go man
it's time to let it go somebody donate
50 said justice for jay fella listen
i understand passions run high when it
comes to art you know people have strong
opinions
the jake fans obviously are not taking
this loss well but everyone i know this
is corny democracy man but
everyone if you were on this bracket you
were a winner already
yeah
but i got a sookie now he was at 52 he's
at 51. it is narrowing
now again
dirt mount fans
suki fans wow get your votes in we're at
10 000 votes
this is do or die
the final suki the
uh
rap
diss track
dirt mouth industrial rock
incredible okay sookie went back up to
52. i'm going to call it here in a
minute guys wow
dirt math fans get those votes in
because i'm going to call it here in a
minute
yep well i'm happy that the final was so
close because it really does reflect
just how talented these guys are
absolutely and um
dude
triller couldn't curate this talent even
if they paid him and isn't that right
and if they said they were gonna pay him
they wouldn't pay him anyway that's so
cool very good point kim that's actually
such a great point to make
all right
listen
i think it's time to call it we're not
seeing much movement
and i'm sorry much movement out there
i'm sorry to say dirt mouth
you were close you took the early lead
but suki
pulled through
with his rapping
dissing wow
king suki has taken
the whole competition wow
hey bro you ever heard of this ryan
cavanaugh dude unbelievable who
ryan cavanaugh ceo of that's the dubs
ain't that company bankrupt bro
did you also know that he had a nanny
and he got sued by that nanny because he
didn't pay her yeah bring him on we
gotta try to frame one of his employees
we're gonna get these guys on
allegedly
well i want to talk to suki
okay
and maybe dirt mouth yeah let's talk did
you get a hold of their mouth
oh you did so let's bring on suki and
dirt mouth
okay
[Applause]
back i better have that [ __ ] in full i
just beat another op and now i'm moving
to the next i ain't never gonna stop hd
part we the best and shout out to the
people that be jealous cause they hate
us shout out keemstar man hearts trisha
nah nevermind i ain't even gonna say
that leasing all these haters cause i
always get the payback hey bro
do me a favor real quick my throat is
gonna be soaked up tomorrow
does ryan cavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein.com and as you get those
what a fun event
yeah
um
pretty much since we started this
whole bracket so i'm gonna run real
quick while we wait i'm not taking a
pause are these guys able to call in
while you're maybe i need like a
catheter here as part of the scorpion
chair um
i sent suki and uh
[Music]
here's the window for it oh sweet okay
and here i'll put it up on the screen
yeah suki and dirt map have the link do
you want
the other two
no just those two second thing the the
reason i'd love to talk to them but i'll
be honest i'm not talking a lot right
now because my throat is like so true
daggers right now dude like yeah it
really does become worse when you talk
it's pretty i know exactly what
i knew
that
this was going to be a hard episode for
me because i heard a lot this morning
but
yeah
yeah we should we make a trailer about
it someone had a good idea um
sean conners
published the winner on trailer i think
that's a pretty good idea
we'll be the first person to post a
trail in
[Music]
the world champion number one ryan
kavanagh hater my man the legend
yes yes
hey can you guys hear me sookie
the man with the golden tongue
thank you thank you the champion
thank you dude how you feeling
honestly i'm like really really [ __ ]
nervous
you're nervous okay i understand that
yeah
yeah just don't say any racial slurs and
you're good
not a problem don't worry yeah that's
just what i like to tell people you know
so are you are you have a lot of
experience as a rapper
um as a not like uh professionally know
i don't like i honestly don't know
anything about technology so it's really
hard for me to like
try to make my own stuff but uh i've
been like just been in bars since i was
like
17 but i'm more of a in the email that i
sent originally
um i told whoever once i read it that i
mostly make indie rock that's kind of
like where i specialize
i used to make rap more but then i don't
know i just never like i feel like i
don't have look with like the sound for
it so then i shifted more into indie
rock
wow so it's not even your specialty and
yet here you are
sitting on top of the throne you are the
number one rank kavanaugh hater besides
me of course
and and what if ryan's lawyers are
listening or ryan himself is there a
message you want to send to him
uh i don't have as much money as ethan
so if you come for me you're not getting
[ __ ]
yeah right exactly there you have it
allegedly
whatever you said in this song is
alleged right buddy
in minecraft yeah yeah i also want to
say
i also want to say uh honestly i wasn't
watching the the stream because i was at
work so like
uh when i got off is when like you guys
started to play my part but shout out to
all the jake fan i think his was really
good too uh everybody's just great yeah
it was awesome and i thought it was yeah
there was a lot of like division with
the jake people
yeah what's the deal with that you know
anything about this jake guy he's he's
he's uh i don't know i i don't really
know anything but he's a he's good yeah
i like his stuff
well suki congratulations uh we're going
to get your paypal you get the big old
500 prize top prize number one
ryan cavanaugh
can eat my dirty hairy [ __ ] uh
chocolate uh cheerios looking
[ __ ]
mine too thanks bro i know that's how
you feel and that's why you're the man
anything else you want to say to the
people
um
if you i mean i don't know if i can if i
could just shout out my indie yeah
yeah thanks man yeah um so on youtube
it's suki music official um it's super
small don't expect anything crazy it
only has like 100 views or something but
it's kind of like my passion project
that's what i do on the side so if you
guys want to check it out
that'd be great and thank you for
everybody you know who voted thanks to
all the participants thanks to the crew
because um
i submitted it pretty late i think and
they must have worked through like labor
day and all that to try to work on my
submission so thanks to all them and
thank you to ethan neela's not here
thanks sir
thank you bro one more time what what's
your youtube channel
oh yeah so sookie
music official three words
music official we'll put the link in the
description as well if you guys want to
check it
out cool thanks man
sorry i'm muted uh love just found the
channel i am wait here let me listen to
one of your songs let's put it up
uh if you if you if you want to listen
to one i would recommend even if but
trigger warning there's some like uh
self-harm stuff in there so maybe if you
don't want to listen to that one i can
suggest like a an easier listen even if
is the one you want me to listen to yeah
let's do it yeah even if i say it's my
best one i think
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
our grand champion
[Music]
[Music]
the heartbreak is the hardest pill to
swallow
i sacrificed everything i was for you i
dedicated all i gave my life for you i
should have never let you break my heart
in two and you don't even know the pain
you put me through and i just wish that
i could be enough for you you broke my
heart at seven in the afternoon my heart
is my guitar and i was out of tune love
you for eternity that was the plan i
want to let you know i'm never coming
back you really hurt my heart i hope you
understand the pain that i have suffered
made me what i am and even
[Music]
here tomorrow the heartbreak is the
hardest pill to swallow
[Music]
[Applause]
sucky
you got me right where i'm most
vulnerable i mean i mispronounced
something
yeah congrats bro yeah thanks guys
everyone check out suki music official
okay
love that for you
all right bro you take care
all right youtube bye guys
see ya
wow
and then we do allen
we do have um the
runner up second place yeah uh dirt
mouth is uh in the lobby right now and
then the two other uh third and fourth
place guys got a hundred what were their
names
uh it was the evil
uh the evil eye
uh
experience yes let me pull it out
let's just say
get whatever they want to plug so we can
put it effect i'm sorry
and
uh
jay fellaini fella yes get their details
we'll put it in the description
but i don't have time unfortunately to
talk to everyone
as my throat is being ripped out of me
you do want to talk to dirt mouth i do
want to talk to dirtmouth our runner-up
standby
dude i gotta say i really like that song
like
damn that was good
same
sookie
[Applause]
i love it i wanna want someone's career
from this podcast
let's make it happen
all right uh der mouth is joining and it
looks like they're getting their audio
hooked up oh maybe now
dirt mouth do we have you hello
there he is can you hear me dirt
mouth
you dirty dirty mouth hello
know
if i compared you to corpse uh
would that be an insult or or a um
problem or a compliment i expected it i
expected it i'm not gonna lie on it
well you got that voice you got that
real grungy
uh bro i'm i'm a girl gang man yeah
you're gang so that's good it helps with
your throat with your temp
timber
timber
timber timber
right got a nice timbre
you smoke
oh yeah yeah
don't stop
gives you that number
give you guys sweet edge bud
thank you
so what what's the deal you're in a band
who made all that rock and roll for us
no um
uh
usually i'm kind of like a product of
the soundcloud era of rap like where
soundcloud got really big as [ __ ]
so
i do a lot of like the scream influence
[ __ ] combined with the rap [ __ ] and the
way that that works in that community is
there's a lot of producers who put their
beats up as free for profit beats and
they like to work with anybody however
there are a lot of people who expect
payment for the beast so there's like
you guys know who you're talking to you
got to make the effort to talk to them
and figure out what you're doing in that
process but it's very very symbiotic
i see
so um
well man you sounded great
thank you i appreciate that yeah
everyone obviously loved it it was a
club were you watching the whole time it
was so close there at the end i was dude
i was sweating i gotta say i gotta say j
fella could have had my ass bro j fella
jay fella if he was in a different
bracket i feel like
dude he could have really had my ass and
then
suki i gotta say even if by suki was
amazing like that song he just played
right now that was amazing
and and jake gang and jake gang i'll say
that too
and dirt mouth
by the way
tons of gifted subs coming in
thank you too proud of our penguin
proud of our family and prolapse penguin
gifted our our saudi pre benefactors
feeling generous today appreciate that
that's for opec
is there anything you want to plug
yeah dude i would love to i appreciate
that um
okay so
i have a spotify with 26 monthly
listeners
and it is literally just the name you
see here i appreciate that damn i thank
you dan thank you everybody
um i also have a sound cloud with the
exact same name that's a little bit
better
um
i will say the ryan kavanaugh this does
not exist on anything i sent it in here
through email it's not on anything
but it could be on something if you guys
want to yeah you should put it up you
want me to do that
i think i mean if you want to i think
people want to listen to it i mean we're
going to post it uh probably on the
highlights channel along with all the
contestants but yeah if you want to post
it on your platforms go feel free yeah
of course i would love any of that man
also uh yeah go ahead yeah one of our
mods sorry avery is spamming um
dirtmouth's uh soundcloud account right
now in the chat so here we go let me
pull that up
definitely add that to the description
of the episode as well
you want me to play one of these god
bless you
uh
okay
um that's a tough choice because you
know a lot of them might be a little
rough and
be outputting but some of them are a
little bit more welcoming i don't know
how to explain it
i'll just click one then eh
oh [ __ ] um uh concussion bro concussion
let me see and where's that one
so those are all my reposts bro those
are not my tracks you gotta the way
soundcloud works you gotta go up and hit
like tracks yeah it's really
inconvenient uh what do you say that
this one's called concussion
here yeah the concussion is pretty cool
all right let's go
this is
dirt mouth
your
runner up
i'm sorry for the cringe if there's any
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
that's concussion everybody that's fire
dude that was dope yo dirt mouth
[Applause]
do you like bones you got like a bones
vibe going on
i mean not quite not quite
uh i do i do love bones bones
no zach i love zach zach i really want
to do a song with you down the road bro
for sure
let's make it happen there we go on
everything bro can i say one laptop put
one last plug in go for it
i gotta say my youtube
is like com is almost non-existent it
exists but there's no content on it
there's just a bio that says it is the
real dirt mouth youtube page
uh there'll be some stuff coming on that
soon especially because of this can i
tell you something
just upload some videos there even if it
doesn't have you know
a video just upload the mp3 or whatever
and we'll link it in the description
people can go
follow you on youtube or soundcloud or
whatever just so you know there's
something for people appreciate that bro
you should upload your captions
thank you bro can i say uh shout out
damian shout out casino the psycho as
well that's the last one i'm sorry
what else you got anything just shout
out the world anybody
yeah bro shout out jack shout out
quentin shout out damien shout out
casino psycho bro shout out all the real
ones bro yeah
don't stop don't stop keep it going
never bro
dirt mouth
all right amazing man shout out ethan
congrats bro
um all right so
thank you man
congrats
uh so if you guys want to check out
sookie dirt mouth or any of the other
i think we'll put also um
j j fila
and the evil eye yeah j fell and evil
we'll we'll plug them guys so feel free
to check them all out please do actually
and to you four guys um
olivia you'll get their payment info
yeah
okay yeah dirt man you're still on the
line right
of course yeah yeah
whatever uh either your paypal or zell
or whatever if you want to send that
over to olivia we'll get you hooked up
honestly bless you guys it's also payday
at my real job so this is
great
honestly
what do you like to do when you get a
lot of cash you you'd like to do
something or you save it oh yeah bro i
uh i'll i'll probably like you know buy
some some caffeine buy some weed
and then save some of it for the next
time i need that
caffeine you just like coffee
no not a euphemism
no bro no no no straight up i drink a
lot i drink way too much caffeine to the
point where like when i don't have it
i'm all groggy and [ __ ] and i don't feel
good wait i'm with you on that wait a b
what's a you what is it a euphemism for
i was just playing but i've heard people
use it to refer to uh other stuff that
in red bull what cocaine yeah
oh because it wakes you up
do you do cocaine
no i don't do no cocaine no no okay
straighten there i've never touched it
in my life never touched the weed
that was a b making that accusation mode
a b
shout out
but not no judgment i mean i've done
cocaine
not peace and love not for a minute but
i've done it i know you've done cocaine
you've done crack yeah did you know i
smoked crack
you loved stuff i think i heard you say
that once you're like that dad like
you're all hip like do you know how i
smoked crack one i smoke crack once son
yeah i just wanted so
all right dirt mouth
god bless you guys thanks for dreaming
bro
take care all right thank you so much
have a great night you too buddy
love that
w fans
w music
www.wereal.com
so um the show has been going for over
three and a half hours oh my god
so much more in the dock but um
maybe we just saved that for friday let
me see i like the dirty dom [ __ ] is
awesome
definitely want to save that
yeah we'll save for friday i can't
believe i did three hours my throat is
so [ __ ] up
i really wanted to do the metaverse guys
tomorrow but i i think i better best not
we definitely if we try and do that
tomorrow
there will definitely be no friday show
i want to do the friday show
yeah and we also have no leftovers next
thursday too so oh
that's right we could do it the
following week there you go cam we'll do
it next week
yeah also
if it wasn't obvious no leftovers
tomorrow
hassan is
doing something called
i don't know i don't really know what
that means
twitch reality show pretty much
is it cutie cinderella who puts that on
i believe so yeah that's impressive she
does that all herself
yeah she's great she probably has some
help but yeah should she do that
um i'm not exactly sure i guess
friday keffels um
the woman who took kiwi farms on
one on one and won
unfucking real kefiels
she's a twitch political commentary
person right
really cool
she's awesome
i don't know if you guys have been fun
it's been a huge story in the been all
dominating even like the last week
i mean it's even gone like uh mainstream
media she did like an interview on cnn
yep
so super excited to talk to her on
friday actually i think it's incredible
what she's accomplished
and um well i'll see you guys on friday
thanks for watching thank you a huge
thank you once again to all the
competitors
yeah everyone who submitted that
unfortunately we didn't have time
to put you in the bracket to everyone
that was in the bracket uh you guys are
all just so amazing blown away by the
talent
blown away and thank you guys and
congratulations to all the winners
so we'll see you guys on friday okay
love y'all take care god bless
ain't that company bankrupt bro yeah
yeah and did you also know that he had a
nanny and he got sued by the nanny
because he didn't pay her and he also
tried to frame one of his employees of
sexual harassment so he wouldn't have to
pay a severance allegedly mine cavanaugh
biggest [ __ ] i ever saw take the money
that you owe me take a trip to panama
trying to bully on me boy i beat you in
the court of law i better get your butt
cheeks ready cause i'm sliding and i'm
raw beat the cases back to back
deformation two i know